You, buffalo warfare, are
to begin the meeting in 30 seconds if everyone would just get their seats and get settled.
Good evening everyone. We welcome you to this meeting of the Huntsville City Council. It
is Thursday, September 10, 2026, 530, and we are met in the council chambers in Huntsville,
Alabama. We welcome all those who have joined us in person and those who are joining us
virtually. We will begin tonight, as is our practice, with an indication. Oh, I should
establish our quorum here. Council members Meredith, Kling, Lillian Robinson are present
and we do have a quorum. We will begin our meetings, as is our practice, with an invocation
given from one of our Huntsville, Alabama public safety chaplains. Tonight we have chaplain
Lori McCauley joining us. And normally we would have the Pledge of Allegiance, but tonight,
since this is Music Month, we are going to actually have a special presentation of the
Star-Spangled Banner performed by the Huntsville City Schools and Maitland Conservatory students
Kennedy Anderson, Kennedy Freeman, and Giselle Patterson. So please remain standing for the
National Anthem. And we will preserve in that order. We will begin with an invocation from
Ms. McCauley.
Our Father, who art in heaven, we thank you right now for the favor of life. Father, please
forgive each one of us, Father, if we have said anything, thought anything, or acted
upon anything that goes against your creation for us. Father, we are inviting you right
now to this room, Father, so that all deliberations, discussions will stay in line in a way that
is in decency and order. Father, they have done their research. Now allow them to wait
for your revelation. They have done their study. Now allow them, Father, to experience
As we go from this place, Father, let us go in one. In Huntsville, we say we are one Huntsville,
Father. So let that spirit of one dwell upon this place so that every action they do will
build up the lives of the citizens that they have been in charge of. In the name of Jesus,
I pray. Amen.
Amen.
Oh, say does that star-spangled banner yet wave
O'er the land of the free
and the home of the brave?
Amen.
Thank you very much, ladies, and thank you as well, Dr. McCauley. Let the record show
that Ms. Watkins has joined us on the dais. We will move on to approval of the agenda.
Item 20B will be taken out of order for action after resolutions and before presentation.
We have also had a request for unanimous consent to consider Item 21G, and we will take that
up when we get to that item. Are there any other changes or additions to the agenda that
anyone is aware of? Is there a motion to approve the agenda as stated?
Second.
A motion from Mr. Kling, second by Mr. Little. All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed? Motion carries. We now have approval of the minutes of previous meetings. For A
is minutes of the regular meeting of the City Council held on August 27, 2026. Are there
any changes or additions to those minutes? Hearing none, those minutes will be accepted
as presented. For B, minutes of the special session of the City Council held on September
1, 2026. Are there changes or additions to those minutes? Seeing none, the minutes will
be accepted as presented. The mayor has two recognitions. 5A is a recognition of Huntsville
City Schools and Maitland Conservatory students Cedric Warren, Kennedy Anderson, Kennedy Freeman,
and Giselle Patterson for their contribution to Music Month. Mayor Bell.
If I could ask Matt Maitland, Matt Mandrella to come up who is our City of Huntsville Music
Officer and introduce some of these young people to us and tell us about the achievements
and what we're doing for Music Month. Thank you, Mayor. Thank you everybody for being
here. Let's bring up our Lee High School students. If you had the privilege to be coming in through
the front door too, we had an amazing performer on the piano, that's Cedric Warren. And so
we're going to be recognizing Cedric, Kennedy, Kennedy, and Giselle. What school do you all
go to and what grade are you in? I go to Lee High School and I'm in 12th grade. I go to
Lee High School and I'm in 12th grade. Hi, I'm Giselle Patterson and I'm in 12th grade.
Hello, I'm Cedric Warren and I'm in the 9th grade. And as part of Music Month, you know,
we incorporate music into City Council meetings and all other places throughout the city.
And this year for these meetings we teamed up with Mario Maitland at the Maitland Conservatory,
one of the most dynamic music educators in the region, actually the country in my opinion.
And so he helped us identify, we wanted to really like kind of give recognition to Hustle
City School kids this year. And so he's helped us identify some amazing talent within our
school system. And they're singing amazingly and playing amazingly, not only here but out
in the community. And we just want to thank you so much for being here. You're welcome.
And more than just being here, thank you for your beautiful music to start us off with.
Music calms the beast and maybe you calm the beast of City Council tonight. Thank you for coming.
Thank you.
And thank you all again for opening our meeting in such a wonderful way.
The next item is, 5B is a proclamation to declare the month of September as Childhood Cancer Awareness Month.
And we have asked to combine that with item 6A, which is a resolution recognizing St. Jude Clinic at
Huntsville Hospital for Women and Children during Childhood Cancer Awareness Month.
Is there a motion to approve the resolution? Motion to approve. Motion for Mr. Lill, second for Mr. Kling.
All in favor please indicate. Aye. Opposed? The motion carries. So we will have these presentations together.
Thank you. And cancer awareness also.
You're multiplying. Look here. Good. Thank you all for coming tonight.
And I'll start with mine first. Whereas childhood cancer remains one of the leading causes of disease related death among children in the United States,
and whereas children diagnosed with cancer demonstrate extraordinary courage, resilience, and determination as they face treatment, recovery, and many other
challenges, I would like to ask you to please stand for the resolution.
And I'll start with mine first. Whereas childhood cancer remains one of the leading causes of disease related death among children in the United States,
and whereas children diagnosed with cancer demonstrate extraordinary courage, resilience, and determination as they face treatment, recovery, and many challenges associated with their
illnesses, whereas the families of the children with cancer often experience significant and emotional, physical, and financial challenges,
and whereas healthcare professionals, researchers, caregivers, volunteers, and charitable organizations work tirelessly to improve outcomes,
advance research, and provide hope and support to children and families affected by cancer,
and whereas increasing awareness of childhood cancer encourages early detection, supports research efforts, promotes community involvement, honors childhood cancer survivors,
and remembers those whose lives have been lost by this devastating disease,
whereas Patricia Haley Charity, Inc. serves children and families impacted by childhood cancer by providing assistance, encouragement,
educational support, resources, and programs to help children with cancer.
And I would like to ask you to please stand for the resolution.
I recognize the dedication of healthcare professionals, caregivers, charitable organizations, and community advocates who support these families.
Now therefore, I, Tommy Battle, Mayor of the City of Huntsville, do hereby declare that I, Tommy Battle,
am a member of the United States of America's National Health Association.
I am a member of the United States of America's National Health Association.
Thank you so much and thank you to my family and foundations and caregivers who support this disease.
And last but not least, 1 million children and families who have lost their lives are the children and families affected by the disease.
Now therefore, I, Tommy Battle, Mayor of the City of Huntsville, do hereby proclaim the month of September is Children's Cancer Awareness Month.
And I present this to you saying thank you so much for all the efforts that you do.
There's no way that we can say enough for the work that y'all do to make this community a better place and to help those who are in need.
So now that we're celebrating recognizing this month those who care for children with cancer,
it's appropriate that we also recognize St. Jude's locally for the work that they do.
Whereas the city council and the mayor of the city of Huntsville, Alabama wish
to recognize St. Jude Clinic at Huntsville Hospital
for Women and Children during Childhood Cancer Awareness Month,
for their dedication to ensuring children in Alabama have access to St. Jude resources
without leaving the comfort of their homes.
Whereas founded in 1962 in Memphis, Tennessee
by Danny Thomas St. Jude Research Hospital began its mission to care for children affected
by fatal diseases, particularly cancer and leukemia.
Whereas four years after St. Jude opened its doors, a significant milestone was reached.
Its first group of patients demonstrated sustained cancer remission,
marking the first cases of acute lymphoblastic leukemia
to be successfully taken off treatment.
And whereas since its opening, St. Jude Research Hospital has become a global leader
in pediatric cancer, reporting an astounding 94% survival rate for patients with ALL,
using therapy that does not expose patients to toxins and radiation.
Whereas over 64 years of operation, St. Jude has helped push the childhood cancer survival rate
in the United States from 20% in 1962 to more than 80% today.
Whereas in 2007, St. Jude opened a clinic in Huntsville in collaboration
with Huntsville Hospital Health Systems that cares for children with cancer and blood disorders,
serving as one of eight St. Jude affiliate clinics in the United States.
Whereas through the diligent work of the clinic, children in Alabama who are affected
by cancer and blood disorders can receive quality care close to home.
Now therefore, be it resolved that the city council and the mayor of the city
of Huntsville, Alabama do hereby commend the St. Jude Clinic at Huntsville Hospital for Women
and Children for furthering the mission of St. Jude Research Hospital,
ensuring local children have full access to successful cancer and blood disease treatment,
bringing researchers one step closer to finding a permanent cure for childhood cancer.
Hi, I'm Dr. Marla Daves, medical director at the St. Jude Clinic here in Huntsville,
and I'm just so grateful that you are taking the time to recognize this cause.
It's so important to us and means so much to us and the people in front
of you have dedicated our lives to fighting this disease.
In front of you, you have nurses, social workers, pharmacists,
administrative staff, dietician, and survivors.
So we are so very grateful to you for recognizing that.
There's 400,000 children diagnosed a year in the world, and around 30 to 40 of those kids are
from North Alabama, and we get to serve those kids, keep them at home and then follow them,
and I just am so grateful that the community supports us and our mission.
Thank you.
're ready.
All right, squeeze in.
you.
And then.
All right.
Okay.
Thank you.
It's going to be a whole lot of up and downing.
Uh, six B is a resolution recognizing the week of September 14 to 18, 2026 as Constitution week in Huntsville is their motion to approve motion from Mr. Little second by the chair. All in favor, please indicate I imposed motion carries and I will ask our friends from the daughters of the American Revolution to come forward.
Thank you for joining us ladies.
Whereas the city council and mayor of the city of Huntsville, Alabama wish to recognize the week of September 14 to 18, 2026 as Constitution Week in Huntsville and recognize the Twickenham town chapter of the National Society, Daughters of the American Revolution for hosting a Constitution Day celebration September 17.
Whereas for over 70 years, Constitution Week has been nationally recognized to remember the meaning of the United States Constitution, America's most important document, which stands as a testament of the diligence of Americans to maintain their liberties, freedoms and rights.
And whereas in 1955, the National Society of Daughters of the American Revolution petitioned the United States Congress to annually set aside September 17 to 23 to be observed as Constitution Week.
Whereas throughout Constitution Week, the National Society of Daughters of the American Revolution has striven to reinforce the responsibility of Americans to protect and defend the Constitution and emphasize that the Constitution is the basic basis for America's heritage.
Whereas Constitution Week provides Americans with opportunities to learn more about this significant document and celebrate the freedoms it grants.
Whereas to formally commemorate the signing of the United States Constitution, the National Society of Daughters of the American Revolution encourages every chapter to host bells across America, a celebration where participants gather to ring bells, much like the church bells rang across Philadelphia when the Constitution was first signed at 4 p.m. on September 17.
1787.
Turn the page.
Whereas the Twickenham town chapter of the National Society of the Daughters of the American Revolution will be hosting their Constitution Day celebration on September 17 at the Signals Museum.
Now therefore be it resolved that the City Council and Mayor of Huntsville, Alabama do hereby recognize the week of September 14 to 18 as Constitution Week in Huntsville and encourage all citizens to study the Constitution and reflect upon the privilege of being an American with the rights and responsibilities that privilege entails.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much. We are so excited about this week coming up. In fact, we're just going to keep going to the 23rd of September.
It's going to be a great thing. Our chapters are going into the schools and teaching about the Constitution.
And we're going to have a wonderful group activity.
Well, five chapter Madison County chapter activity Constitution Day event celebration with Ben Franklin and the Rockets City Chorus and games and all kinds of fun things.
And there'll be cake. So it's going to be a lot of fun and Mayor Battle. I hope you'll be attending.
Anyway, thank you so much for this honor. We really appreciate our community.
And thank you so much for the board for allowing us to come here today.
Thank you for for for giving us this opportunity.
Thank you.
Now we have the item that we are going to be taking out of order, which is item.
Twenty B. 20 B.
Is a resolution authorizing the acceptance of donations. Is there a motion to approve motion for Mr. Little second from Mr. Meredith.
All in favor, please indicate any opposed.
The motion carries. We have here with us tonight. Representative Laura Hall, Representative Hall.
Welcome. And we I believe you have a presentation tonight.
Well, we don't have any whereas are now there for be it resolves for you tonight, but we do want to say thank you for the recognition of the ten thousand dollars you have given year in and year out to help aquatics here in the city of Huntsville, more specifically at the shower center.
How many years you've been doing this.
Fifteen years she has been giving money faithfully to to the city of Huntsville to be applied at the Richard Shower Center, the Aquatics Program and tell us a little bit about that.
Thank you, Mayor and members. The purpose of the funding is really to make sure those children who do not know how to swim have an opportunity to learn how to swim.
And I must say the staff at the shower center is certainly an amazing staff in terms of their patience and their love for their job and also making sure that our children have an opportunity to be able to swim because we find that if you look at the statistics, especially in the African and American community, we always have this challenge of a child die in because they drown.
I had a cousin when I was twelve and that happened to so I learned to swim at age thirty. So if I figure if I can learn to swim at age thirty, the child should have a much better time.
So thank you for the opportunity and we look forward. I think the number that we have reached at this point is like one hundred and forty six for this year.
That is great. And let us say now therefore be it resolved. Thank you so much for your contribution.
Thank you, Representative Hall for your generosity.
We will move on to announcements and presentations. You will for the audience and council members. We are entering September, which in addition to being all the recognized months and weeks that we've just gone through is also the month when we consider our budget.
The budget will be read into introduction tonight. We will have a work session on September 18th at 11 a.m. where the budget and other attached items will be presented to the council and council members will have an opportunity to ask questions.
Also share any amendments that they plan to make it at the final session, which will be September 24th when we will have the regular council meeting when we will approve the budget.
So for everyone's attention, council members and public be aware that that's how we're going to be handling things.
Now we will move on to a presentation. Seven a is a presentation on the sound diplomacy music impact study.
As I stated earlier, among other things, September is music month. So we felt that this would be an appropriate time to have a presentation on the music audit with us tonight is Matt Mandrella and Mr. Mandrella.
Time is yours. All right. Good evening. And it's a very exciting time for music in Huntsville and really appreciate the opportunity to share a quick update on where we are and what the latest data tells us about our music sector's growth and its future.
Back in 2018, watching hospitals first music audit was a bit of a leap of faith. We were the first city in the United States to take a this kind of comprehensive data driven approach to intentionally growing our music ecosystem.
We wanted to better understand hospitals own creative identity and how music could strengthen our quality of life, diversify our economy, attract talent and help shape the city we were becoming.
The first audit identified strengths that were already here, but it also revealed opportunities that we had not fully tapped into.
It gave us a roadmap of actionable recommendations that the city and our community partners have steadily worked on advancing.
And that work helped lead to the creation of a my role, the Huntsville Music Office, major investments like the Orion Amphitheater and a much more intentional approach to growing our ecosystem.
And so eight years later, we went back to sound diplomacy to ask how far we'd come. And the data tells a pretty remarkable story.
Let's start with the big picture. In 2018, Huntsville's music ecosystem generated approximately one hundred and ninety one point two million in total economic output.
And that's adjusted to inflation. Today, that number has grown to two hundred and seventy eight point two million.
That's an increase of roughly forty five percent. And when we talk about the music economy, we're talking about much more than concerts.
It includes artists, venues, festivals, music education, retail, radio, studios and all the businesses that support music activity.
The simplest takeaway from this is that music is now definitely a significant and measurable part of Huntsville's overall economy.
Talk about jobs. I think one of the most exciting indicators about this is the employment growth.
The original audit identified nine hundred and eighty six direct music related jobs.
Today, Huntsville's music ecosystem supports three thousand forty seven jobs across the broader regional economy.
And that's two thousand four hundred and twenty four jobs directly within the music sector.
That direct workforce is nearly two and a half times the size it was when our work began.
And so that's an increase of about one hundred and forty five percent in the employment sector.
And so that means real employment opportunities not only for artists and performers, but also venue and production professionals, educators,
technicians, promoters and many others. So the ecosystem hasn't simply just gotten busier.
We've grown at larger, deeper and increasingly professionalized.
Another way that economists measure the strength of an industry is through gross value added or GVA.
So essentially that's the value the sector itself contributes to the economy.
Today, Huntsville's music ecosystem contributes approximately one hundred and sixty two million in gross value added.
And this chart shows us where that value is being generated.
Creation is the artists and the songwriters making the music.
Production is the studios, producers and services that turn that creativity into a finished product.
Distribution is how music reaches audiences and markets.
Exhibition is the live side of the industry, such as festivals, venues, concerts and promoters.
And transversal is the support system around it all, such as music education, management, equipment, nonprofits and other professional services.
As you can see, exhibition and support services account for the vast majority of the economic value currently being generated.
And so that also reflects something we already know.
Huntsville has become very good at presenting and supporting live music, but it also highlights one of our clearest opportunities for future growth.
And that's the creation and production aspects of things.
And so the next phase of our work is not just going to be about bringing more music to Huntsville.
It's going to be helping more music get created here, recorded here, developed here and ultimately commercialized from here.
We can also physically see the growth of the ecosystem across the city since the initial audit.
In 2018, we had one hundred and sixty three music related assets mapped throughout the city.
Today we've grown that number to two hundred and fifteen.
So that's a thirty two percent increase.
Those assets include venues, recording and rehearsal spaces, music education spots, retail production companies and other businesses and organizations that make the music ecosystem function.
So this isn't simply just a story about having more concerts.
It's infrastructure underneath Huntsville's music industry that has grown significantly, too.
Here's one I'm especially proud of.
Huntsville now hosts more than two thousand two hundred music events every year.
That's everything from major nights at the Orion and the Bon Braun Center to local venues, festivals, neighborhood events, songwriter nights and grassroots community performances.
And that variety is important and it matters.
A strong music city isn't really defined by one venue, one artist or one festival.
It's defined by the depth and diversity of opportunities happening throughout our entire community.
And as part of the San diplomacy work, they did some specific case studies into our partner venues and events.
The Bon Braun Center, as well knows, been the centerpiece of Huntsville's music and entertainment landscape for now more than 50 years.
And its economic impact continues to be extraordinary.
And twenty twenty five alone, VBC concerts generated approximately thirty seven point five million in economic impact and an estimated five point three million in local tax revenue.
And that activity stands well beyond the walls of the VBC.
It brings people downtown. It fills hotels, restaurants and supports businesses throughout our community.
The VBC remains one of the clearest examples of how music and entertainment infrastructure can generate real economic value for Huntsville.
The Orion amphitheater has expanded that impact even further.
In its first 18 months, the Orion welcomed approximately three hundred and fifteen thousand attendees and generated eighty five point two million in economic output.
So nearly one hundred and fifty thousand of those tickets were sold to non-local residents and attendees.
So that's significant because those people are choosing to come to Huntsville because of music and also spending money throughout our community while they're here outside of the amphitheater.
And so that's a very form of a very tangible form of cultural tourism that we're able to prove.
The South Star Music Festival demonstrated Huntsville's potential on another scale.
The festival, even though we lost the second day due to the hurricane, it generated an estimated twenty four point one million in economic impact in that single day.
While the national attention surrounding its launch generated approximately two hundred and eighteen million dollars in earned media value.
Those are remarkable numbers.
And when we put that together with the BBC and the Orion, they tell a pretty clear story that Huntsville isn't simply hosting more shows.
Music is creating jobs, it's driving tourism and generating real economic and cultural value for our city.
Industry partnerships.
We are building a sustainable city can only be about bringing great artists and events to Huntsville.
We also have to create pathways for Huntsville artists and music professionals to build careers here.
That's why relationships and partnerships we've established with organizations like the Recording Academy, Universal Music Group and East Irish Studios in Nashville are so important.
They help connect our local creative community to industry expertise, professional networks and opportunities that frankly they don't have here in Huntsville currently.
And they help us build and strengthen the business side infrastructure around our ecosystem needed for that long term sustainable growth to to keep this moving upward.
Because ultimately we want Huntsville to be more than just a great place to play and experience music.
We want it to be a great place to build a career in music.
And so what is next?
That brings us to that very important question.
The updated audit gives us another roadmap that we'll be focusing on.
We need to continue investing in the things that have led to our success to get us here, like the artist support, music education, the festival and the venue infrastructure.
But we also need to really focus and continue expanding the business side of the industry.
We need more studios, more managers and more agents and just more overall licensing support and other professional services that are needed to help artists sustain those careers here in Huntsville where they don't feel like they need to move to Nashville.
Huntsville has become very, very good at bringing music here.
And our next opportunity is helping more music careers and businesses grow from here.
That doesn't mean moving away from live music by any means.
It just means building on the success we already have so that more of the talents, intellectual property, businesses and economic values surrounding music can be created, developed and retained here in Huntsville.
We've built the live music economy and now we need to build more of the industry around it.
One final piece of our story that I'm especially proud of.
Huntsville is now helping lead this work nationally.
The Huntsville Music Office is a proud founding member of the Association of Music Offices.
That's a recently launched new national network bringing public music offices and industry partners together from across the country to share best practices, strengthen connections between cities and states and work on advancing the role that music can play in economic development, quality of life and community building.
For Huntsville, it's another sign that the work we've started here eight years ago is now part of a much broader national conversation.
And we're at the table alongside music offices and partners from across the country and industry partners like the Recording Academy who produces the Grammy Awards.
That matters because cities and states are increasingly looking at music now not just as entertainment but as part of their broader economic and community development strategy.
And it's exciting because Huntsville isn't just participating in that conversation.
We're actively helping shaping it and we're actively helping lead it.
And I think that says a lot about how far we've come.
Eight years ago we were looking around the country for models and today Huntsville is a model that other cities and communities are looking at.
Huntsville is a very special place.
We all love it here. That's why we're here.
And while the work we're doing is about economic output, jobs, tourism, venues and businesses and investment and all that exciting stuff, it's also about building a city where people can live, create, perform and grow.
One of the most meaningful things we consistently hear from artists is that Huntsville doesn't just show up as an audience.
We show up as a community and artists feel welcomed here.
They feel supported and they see Huntsville as a place where they can not only go on stage but they can build a life and not just play a show.
So eight years ago Huntsville made a deliberate decision to treat music as more than just entertainment.
And I just want to say thank you to Mayor Battle, the support of our city council for that process, all our partners and our local music community.
And we've made tremendous progress.
And this audit gives us data to show how far we've come and a roadmap on where we're going next.
And so we've built the stage and now it's our opportunity to build even more careers, businesses and create a value around it.
So thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Mandrell and thank you to you and your mighty team of two for everything that you have accomplished together.
Council members, do you have any comments or questions?
Mr. Little. Good job, Matt.
And thanks for a great presentation.
I'm just curious how the grant programs are going.
It's going great. It's going really great.
We haven't maxed out our annual 50k yet.
We weren't expecting to, but I think we got close to 40 this year.
And we're seeing it's interesting because we're hearing a lot of stories and testimonials about people that are moving here specifically to take advantage of that program.
And so it's really exciting.
Good. Great. Thank you.
Keep up the good work.
Any other comments?
Thank you again for the presentation, for the work you're doing and for demonstrating impact in our community.
Thank you.
We have no matters with outside legal representative.
We will move on to public hearings to be held.
Nine A is a public hearing authorizing community development to assess the cost of cutting overgrown grass and weeds against certain properties and consideration of a resolution pertaining to the same.
Mr. Erwin.
Good evening, Council Member Sparrow and the Community Development Department.
This is a public hearing on a resolution authorizing community development to assess the cost for cutting overgrown grass and weeds at certain properties.
The resolution before you authorizes assessments in the amount of $10,937.59.
The resolution covers 36 total properties, 21 head owners inside the city limits of Huntsville, six were out of the city limits of Huntsville with nine out of state owners.
Thank you.
The public hearing is now open.
Is there anyone who wishes to comment on this item?
Please come to the microphone here, sir.
If you will give us your name and address for the record.
Hello, my name is Mohammed Arunajad.
I'm the owner of property at 1330 Chikamaga Trail.
I received a notice from the Department of Community Development.
It said I had some like three weeks to get more property shaped up because tenants had moved out.
And usually those of you who own a rental property, you know, when they leave, they leave everything behind.
So the condition property did not look that good.
So when I saw the notice, they reacted to get everything shaped up and clean.
They have a nice picture of it.
But not knowing somewhere in the notice, it said they had to cut the grass by certain date.
So the date was missed, but the property was clean.
So when we got the notice of 242 dollars to pay for the area, which is 10 by 25 yards to cut for 242, they called the office.
They said, well, if you cut it, 242 is not reasonable anyway.
And plus, it was really negligence on my part, not really in the whole citation.
So at this point, I really feel that if I pay 242.66, it's not going to really destroy my economic condition.
But I really feel that it's not really fair that the situation, that everything written embedded together.
So I'm glad to have this opportunity to show up and tell you about my case.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir, for your comments.
Are there anyone else who wishes to comment?
Seeing none, the public hearing is closed.
Is there a motion to approve the resolution motion from Mr. second from Mr. Kling?
Second from Mr. Little.
Council members, do we have any questions for Mr. Irwin?
If I understood correctly, it sounds like he's gotten his grass cut in the intervening time.
So if you'll get out there and it's all good.
Correct.
So we have a 14 day notice and the property remains as a violation upon the re-inspection.
We issue a work order and go cut.
So at any point up to the time we arrive on the site with the equipment to remove the grass, then the owner has the opportunity to do it themselves.
Any other questions?
On order, please indicate aye.
Any opposed? Motion carries.
Thank you, council members.
Mr. Renich, if you want to have further conversation with Mr. Irwin, you could do that.
Mr. Irwin, would you like to take Mr. Renich out outside?
Thank you.
9B. 9B is a public hearing on the proposed creation of a tax increment financing district tentatively named TIF D8 pursuant to Alabama Code Section 11-99-1.
And this is a public hearing only council members.
There will be no action taken tonight.
This is simply another step in the process of approving a TIF.
Mr. Davis is here to make a presentation and then we will open the hearing.
Thank you, Madam President. Shane Davis, Director of Urban Economic Development.
Good evening, council members.
You may recall the last city council meeting.
You passed a resolution directing the administration to come back and present you a proposed TIF project plan.
This project plan would be in Limestone County portion of Annex, Huntsville.
So we've been working for about three weeks to put this draft plan together and tonight we're proud to present it to you and the general public.
So much like the recent TIF for downtown, I do want, especially for the public's sake, to just quickly give a little bit of background on TIF increment financing.
Since 2000, the city of Huntsville has been very successful in establishing tax increment financing districts that are permitted by Alabama law to finance public infrastructure projects.
The principle is very simple.
You take future property tax revenues in a defined district.
So think of property that is not currently developed, but as it develops, it creates a new tax base.
That new tax base would fund public infrastructure.
That public infrastructure is put in ahead of time to induce or entice that private investment.
We get routinely asked with the general public, is this a tax increase?
It is absolutely not a tax increase.
The millage rate that you pay in Huntsville stays the same.
That actually has to go by vote of the people to change property taxes.
So this is just the way we would use those future property taxes to fund public infrastructure.
Lastly, the existing tax base within that district continues to go to the tax recipients as they do today.
So we're not taking any existing revenue away from our general fund, in this case the Limestone County general fund, or any of the school systems within this tax district.
So they'll continue to get whatever they got last year.
It will be any future revenues that would be created as a result of this infrastructure.
I do want to point out this proposed TIF VIII district is different than some of the others.
This would be our third district under the major 21st Century Manufacturing Act.
TIF VI and VII, TIF VI has closed, was the first 21st Century Manufacturing Zone TIF district.
The Mazda Toyota Manufacturing Project brought before you in the Limestone County Commission, TIF VII.
That is active and really moved the needle out there with public infrastructure and roads and utilities and the things.
And through those two TIF districts, what we have created out in that area is over $3 billion of private investment that's now on the tax rolls and over 14,000 new jobs.
So the proposed TIF VIII district would be created under the major 21st Century Manufacturing Zone Act.
And the TIF VIII district would designate for the future Eli Lilly project that's recently announced and would get under construction sometime next year.
That would be our designated manufacturing zone under this Act with the TIF.
You've got to designate a manufacturing zone and we'll get into that momentarily.
So let's get into the actual project plan.
Just wanted to provide that background, the differences, and also the general public.
This is nothing about any type of tax increase to anyone.
So the project area, you can see kind of dashed in the black dashed area and shaded in the light shading, would consist of just over 9,000 acres.
This would be very similar in size to TIF VII that we did that's to the north and actually goes all the way to I-65.
The boundary, generally speaking, would be Old Highway 20 to the north, Swancott Road to the south, County Line Road to the east, there at the airport you see on the right hand side of the screen,
and Prior Road to the west, and Prior Road is just west of Exit 3 on the south side of I-565.
So what would the project plan look like?
So as a result of the city's public infrastructure investments, the proposed TIF VIII plan would capture future property tax millages from future new development or redevelopment properties within that area I just showed you.
So what would we capture of that tax base?
It would be 54 mills total, 35 mills of the city of Huntsville, only 5.5 mills of the education portion, 13.5 mills of Limestone County portion of the overall millage.
The overall millage of this area for Huntsville is 60.5 mills.
So there would be 6.5 mills that would not be captured in this TIF District.
Upon the creation of TIF District 8, the full implementation of the proposed public investments, we certainly anticipate that it would yield significant new private investment in these areas.
If I go back to this map, if you look, it's predominantly undeveloped.
That is the purpose of a TIF, is to induce or entice, especially under the 21st Century Manufacturing Act, is go make those public investments such that you will entice new private investment to add to the tax rolls.
That new investment helps our schools, it helps our general fund, it certainly helps Limestone County's general fund in the future.
As a result, preliminary modeling suggests that upon completion of these investments that I'll go through momentarily, we'll produce a new tax base of somewhere between 20 and 25 million dollars annually.
That certainly would get distributed between the City of Huntsville, our educational partners, the way the millage is broken out, and Limestone County Commission.
So let's go through the list.
I apologize for the font kind of not aligning on this computer, but it's a pretty long list.
It's very similar to TIF 7 in that with the Eli Lilly project, there's an opportunity for us to get a lot done in this TIF District.
So Greenbrier Parkway and Greenbrier Road improvements at a cost of 8 million dollars will go into a map and show you these locations momentarily.
Interstate I-565 Exit 3 improvements at Alabama Highway 20 at 15 million dollars.
With the amount of growth that we've had in industrial recruitment out there, we have a need with the way shift work happens in this Limestone-Greenbrier area.
Exit 3 in the mornings backs up as people are coming from Huntsville westbound to go to these 14,000 jobs.
That's what we wanted. We want our community to take advantage of the jobs we created.
So this would make improvements to alleviate that congestion at I-565 at Exit 3.
Swancott Road widening, this would go from Exit 3 south to Bowling Boulevard to the airport.
It's an area we believe will see significant growth, but this project also helps Eli Lilly and others to have a better route to the intermodal facility for the air cargo at our airport.
It takes traffic off the interstate, takes truck traffic in that manner.
It was one of the commitments for Eli Lilly, is to have a more direct access route or a secondary route.
If there's a wreck on the interstate, it's pretty much a single point of failure.
So again, it's heavy on transportation.
Prior road improvements, we'll get into that.
A portion of that is a relocation of Prior Road and one is an improvement of Prior Road.
You'll see an amount momentarily.
In other words, people's road improvements, so that runs east-west off Swancott Road to Prior Road.
And that will be in support of a new K Elementary School.
It is number 8 at $40 million.
County Line Road relocation upgrades, that would move County Line Road from its current location from I-565 south to Bowling Boulevard west.
Why would we want to do that?
One, it abuts the existing west runway and the master plan of the airport and from an industrial recruitment, we have lost significant projects that need access to a runway.
The reason we've lost those projects is not due to workforce, not due to great projects and project sites and great utilities.
It's been the delay that you would have to relocate County Line Road before someone could make that private investment.
So we think it's the opportunity under this TIF to go ahead and move it to its permanent home.
Our long-term transportation plan is to move County Line Road west.
It is the long-term plan of Huntsville International Airport, too.
So we're following a plan that's been in place.
We now believe through this process we have the funds, should this get approved, to go ahead and complete that infrastructure improvement.
As I just mentioned, a new K-8 Elementary School in partnership with Huntsville City Schools at $40 million upgrades to Fire Station 18.
This would expand the fire station there on Greenbrier Road and Greenbrier Parkway that's supplying not only residential response but industrial response.
It would allow our fire department to add a ladder truck, which is very much needed in this industrial corridor.
And then multiple sanitary sewer improvements throughout that district to entice new private investment.
And then the last is the 21st century manufacturing zone land.
So Councilmembers, we purchased the Eli Lilly site several years ago.
But before Council approved that purchase, you passed a resolution that was a reimbursement resolution.
So should we land the right industrial project that the taxpayer, the City of Huntsville, would be recouped the amount of money we paid for that property, this would do that reimbursement to the city.
So the total cost of all 11 projects is $230 million.
I do want to remind you by state law, under no circumstance without an amendment, both by this body and the Limestone County Commission, shall we exceed 230 million.
Not that you can't, but it would be a very public process to amend the TIF district.
We feel confident in these numbers moving forward.
So let's kind of zoom in on these so you can kind of see more in general what we are talking about.
So again, the Greenbrier Parkway, Greenbrier Road, shown in bullet number one, that is to make intersection improvements to help both Polaris and be one of the main entrances to Eli Lilly.
So again, we want to make sure traffic moves smoothly, that people can get to and from work and back to their homes.
A lot of truck traffic in Greenbrier Parkway area.
And we've just seen with the growth that this is a much needed project.
Number two, as I showed you, you can see all the turning movements that we'll be working on at exit three of I-565.
And Alabama 20 signalized intersection is just on the north side of the interstate.
And that is the bottleneck.
So we want to make major improvements there.
As you come off the interstate and want to go north, you come upon a light that's Alabama 20 that causes the congestion.
Swancock Road widening, bullet number three, as you can see, goes from that exit three due south and then turns east and west and would terminate there at the current county line road in Boeing Boulevard intersection.
Prior road improvements is number four, that you can see the square orange box you see is the location of the new K-8 school.
So prior road is a very under designed from a road standard road right now.
So what we want to do is there's a small section to the west of the school site that would be removed and be relocated where you see the bullet number four run east and west to tie back into the existing prior road.
As you see further south, the other number four nomenclature that runs east and west or left and right on your screen would be the improvement to the existing prior road.
So part of it is a relocation and then improving the remainder portion of prior road.
People's Road, as you can see, is on the north side of the school that comes off the new Swancock Road design that would go to be the primary access point for the new K-8 school.
There's a new road that you see is number six that would connect from People's Road down to the relocated or the improved prior road that runs north and south, essentially parallel to Swancock Road.
This does two things, allow circulation and safety around the new school, but it will also induce what is the TIF district supposed to do, a lot of new development, both commercial and residential and the like in that area that you see is 99 percent undeveloped.
Number seven would be the relocation of County Line Road and upgrades. When I speak to upgrades, that would be intersection upgrades near the interstate exit to the north of the airport runway.
Move that the road would parallel in a westbound direction on the south side of the interstate and then go due south and connect into the new widened Swancock Road.
And then lastly, for this slide is a new K-8 school. This school, I do want to remind you, is we have been able to work to donate, have the land donated to the school system at no cost to schools, and this TIF will actually produce the school for the school system.
This school, I do want to remind you that as part of the Huston City School's $600 million ongoing capital plan, this school was in that plan. So it will allow them to take and go further to some of our existing schools.
So we see it as a win-win for everybody involved.
The last three, number nine, Fire Station 18 improvements, as I mentioned, it would fund expansion of the existing fire station to make way for a new ladder truck service for the western corridor.
And then 10 would be just general sewer improvements in this undeveloped area so we can prepare for new private investments.
And lastly, as you can see, is the Eli Lilly site would be the reimbursement to the city of the $22 million that was spent on this.
So one of the things we always want to show and to you and the general public is, you know, this is a lot of investment. This is a lot of projects. It's creating a district.
And so what is that return? Where are the areas that we see private investment occurring? You know, I just told you somewhere between 20 and $25 million annually of new taxes to be paid once these investments are.
So again, this TIF district is in predominantly undeveloped areas of city of Huntsville, Limestone County.
So this shows you eight areas that we've identified. Should we make these road improvements? Put these utilities in certainly with a new school brings new rooftops.
And these would be the pocket areas. Certainly the Eli Lilly site. There's, you know, about 300 acre industrial site just north or adjacent to that.
And then the south side of 20 and then you come back on the south side of the interstate.
So what are the next steps? So here we are tonight, September 10th. We're holding the public hearing by Alabama law and we present this to you.
You do have the opportunity to make comments and changes as we move forward. That's what this public process is about.
So towards the end of this month, we will have meetings or a meeting with designated representatives for the tax recipients that deferred to the state of Alabama.
There's only two of those. You, the city of Huntsville and Limestone County Commission.
So just as we did with the Madison County Commission recently, they will represent one designated most likely will be Chairman Daly Limestone County Commission and we'll meet after this meeting.
We will actually send them this draft project plan just as you've been presented.
And then we will meet to go through the plan in detail, see if there's any concerns or changes.
And then the 1st of October, the council president would mail out to the deferred tax recipients.
That would be each city council member would get a final copy of what this tip plan would be.
And also the Limestone County Commission of what we refer to as the final project plan, the one that would be the final project plan.
The one that would to be voted on for adoption of a tip a district tentatively.
We're looking at October 5th, the Limestone County Commission would vote to approve their confirmation of the tip district.
And then on October 8th at a regular city council meeting be the first meeting in October, this body would determine take a vote to adopt tip a district in Limestone County.
So should both Limestone County and this body approve those October 12th, finance director would make application to the Limestone County tax center.
There's a top of there that would take the legal description that's in this project plan along with the resolutions by this body in Limestone County to designate and capture those property tax pins of vacant land.
So that they create the district in the collection going forward.
And after that, it would be to move forward and starting to the design and getting these projects built.
Councilman, is there any questions you may have?
We could hold off on that until after we've held the public hearing.
So the public hearing is now open. Is there anyone here who wishes to comment on this plan?
Please come forward, give us your name and address for the record.
Yes, Jerry Cox.
Queensbury Drive, Huntsville.
It's hard to believe. I believe that Mr. Davis said that tip one was in 2000.
I was sitting in the audience of the council meeting at that meeting and was quite concerned about this new tool that the city was adopting.
General Fanning, he was in charge of implementing the thing.
And as I asked some questions, he was somewhat dismissive, which a general would do to an E5.
But it was it was a lack of understanding of this new tool that the state was providing to the cities.
Once I went to the library, the law library and read the law, the state law and looked at the implementation, the general was not quite so dismissive of my question.
But of course, anyone would have a concern when when when a governing body adopts a tool and the first two words are tax increment.
So I knew we knew we needed to hang on to our pocketbook or something.
But now we're aware of what tax increment is.
And the other one was the area.
In those days, I believe this I believe we called it a manufacturing something, I guess, is a change to what those initial districts were for.
And and so it was not covering an area like Mr. Davis is described here in this in this district.
So but also, as I read the law, I had some concern about the area of that of that first tier.
But in the end, the city was in good hands with the with General Fanning's implementation of that first tier and several tips thereafter.
And I know for sure that the city will be in good hands with Mr. Davis implementing to district eight.
One thing is, I was thinking, well, I'm going to leave it at that.
Thank you very much. Thank you, Mr. Say, Mayor.
It's good that you are still using these tools because they are in the best interest of the city. Thank you, Mr. Cox.
Is there anyone else who wishes to comment?
James and Olivia Avenue, Huntsville, a couple of questions.
This the land shown inside that map is all within the city of Huntsville right now.
Is that correct?
This is an opportunity for comments.
So we can write down the questions and then we will ask.
OK, if the land is all within the city of Huntsville, is it possible to let us know what the current tax take is?
Is it possible to let us know what the current tax take is from all of that land right now so that we can see down the line what the improvement was?
We should have a baseline.
And also, I'm wondering, you didn't mention that the city school board has to give approval.
And I know that in the past they have had to because the deferred taxes or the increases over the course of the TIF that don't go to the schools.
And if they use that money to pay off the TIF, are then deductions from what the city would otherwise, city schools would otherwise be getting.
So I was just curious whether or not that was something that had changed under this TIF.
And you don't need to answer it now.
You're not allowed to answer now, but we can talk after.
Thank you, Mr. Linderholm.
Is there anyone else who wishes to comment?
Just want to say I'm.
Name and address for the record.
My name is Darren.
I live off of the Thames Avenue in Huntsville.
Last name, Darren.
Virhaga.
Thank you.
I just want to say I'm very excited about this.
I'm very interested and excited about the development and growth that will be happening in this new TIF.
It's crazy how far Huntsville is going.
And I hope that we can also take this opportunity, since we are expanding and building new roads, as someone that's lived off of County Line and seen the crazy traffic that's there.
More lanes won't be the only option forever.
I hope we can explore new avenues such as like bus lanes or greenways or other things like that, especially if that area explodes like how the surrounding Madison area has been, because there's a ton of people have moved in in just the past three years.
That's all.
Thank you, Mr. Hugg.
Is there anyone else who wishes to comment?
Council members before...
Good afternoon.
My name is Sasha Erby.
And thank you for your presentation, Mr. Davis.
Your address, Ms. Erby.
Pardon?
Address, Ms. Erby.
Your address.
205 McDonald Avenue, Northwest, Huntsville.
I just had one quick question.
I wanted to know what was the projected timeframe for the proposed items?
And again, this is...
If you'll address those questions to us, we'll ask them.
Yeah, absolutely.
So projected timeframe for...
The proposed items.
Thank you.
Okay, very good.
Anyone else wishing to comment?
Council members before we close the hearing, what comments do you have?
Any comments or questions?
Okay, Mr. Klink.
I believe some of this...
I'll give it to Mr. Davis.
Oh, microphone.
For Mr. Davis, or possibly this would go to the finance director.
And again, you kind of touched on, you know, the concept of tips and, you know, confusion.
Not a tax increase, right?
Yes, sir.
Correct.
Just one more time.
Not a tax increase.
Historically, on these tips, and, you know, this deals with what we're talking about, but historically,
have any of the tips that we've had in the past been late in paying back on the schedule that they're supposed to?
Not that I'm aware of.
They typically, as Ms. Smith, our finance director, gives you a tip update about once a quarter.
They're always tracking ahead.
I believe, if I'm correct, we only have two active now.
I guess with the new one, downtown three.
But, you know, with tip nine, we'll be our third, but really only two that's taken on any debt, per se.
But they're all tracking very well.
Okay.
I don't want to cross over too much, but I'm just trying to get clarified.
A gentleman had asked me a question beforehand.
I'm just trying to get some information.
The school system is not being penalized whenever we do a TIF.
Is that correct?
Like this TIF?
That's correct.
So I do want, if I can take a moment, Council President, answer.
Your question is related to the question the gentleman asked.
Yes.
So the two that have to vote are deferred tax recipients.
So those are people who assess taxes and collect them.
So our educational partners, both in the county and the city, do not assess.
They do not place a millage on property.
Both you and a county does that, certainly the state of Alabama.
We collect and then we disperse by the millage that we set up that goes to education.
So the two bodies that would have to vote on this TIF would be you,
the city council and the Limestone County Commission.
Now, to answer Councilman Cleen's question is one, the existing tax base that this district is producing today
continues to go to everyone that the millage gets cut up.
That goes to really four bodies.
It goes to City Hall, General Fund.
It goes to the Limestone County Commission.
Limestone County Schools and Huntsville City Schools.
Both the Limestone County Commission sends whatever millage that they've got designated
to go to their school system just as you do.
But you and the Limestone County Commission are the two deferred tax recipients.
You assess taxes or put before and collect those.
So one, it's not a tax increase.
Two, we are not taking any existing revenues away from education,
nor City of Huntsville General Fund or Limestone County General Fund.
It is only the future revenues that would not most likely be seen without these investments.
These are very rural two-lane roads.
I do want to answer the other question.
By state law, a TIF district, all the land within that district must be within our seat limits.
Yes, you actually see some areas that says the word out.
You may not be able to see it at that scale.
Those are carved out.
So if you look at the exhibit of this plan, you've got a very long legal description.
It's about four pages.
But then it's got what we call less than except where we are carving out those pieces
that are not inside the seat limits of Huntsville.
So only the land that's within our corporate limits.
Did I answer all those, Councilman Klink?
I got one last one.
This may be you.
This may be the finance director.
And this may be a stumper.
And I don't mean it to be the way.
Do you have a general ballpark estimate from all the TIFs how much revenue
has gone to the school system for capital projects?
And again, I know that's a stumper.
Plus or minus 10, 20, 50 million, whatever.
I would estimate that we're probably close to $100 million.
We can get you that number.
I know we have built several schools in a TIF.
We have maybe not fully built, but we've built infrastructure to support a new school
or expansion of a school.
If you've looked at most of our TIFs, we have tried to put an educational component
where it makes sense.
We've done some TIFs like the one downtown.
We are helping with a new school over on Lowe, the new middle school.
But that project was underway.
So we're helping with public infrastructure in and around that school to make it safer
and the congestion.
And that's taking away from the school system's budget that they would have had to go do that, right?
So if you go look at the history of our TIFs, where we've been able to contribute,
if that TIF district has had a school or the school system has in the future said,
this is where we want a school, we've tried to help our educational partners always.
Thank you, sir.
I believe you answered all of the questions, Mr. Davis, except for projected time frame.
And I think the question there was, how soon do you think, are you projecting that this TIF will pay off?
Yeah.
So it was a very good question.
And there's actually rules around that in the TIF district.
So all projects, all 11 projects must be started.
So construction must have commenced within the first five years.
If that project hasn't commenced, that project just goes off the project plan.
Because the goal is to get these projects employed very, very quickly,
induce private investment so you can pay off the debt for these projects,
and then see the gains, those new property taxes, see everybody get that return on investment,
the school system, this body, Limestone County Commission.
So we'll have five years to get them all under construction.
Once they're under construction, they'll run their normal course of completion.
So it will happen very quickly.
Thank you. Mr. Meredith, do you have comments or questions?
Yes. I'd like to thank you, Mr. Davis, and your entire team that has been working on this.
It's a wonderful product that you've put together, and I look forward to seeing it come to fruition.
I would like a copy of this slide deck, if at all possible.
And out west, we suffer quite a bit, probably more than any other district,
of infrastructure not keeping up with annexation and development.
This is a way to totally ensure within this TIF district that infrastructure actually is ahead of the development.
That's very well said.
The roads that are going to be created and updated around the new school site, perfect example.
And of course, there isn't fiber there for the most part.
So fiber will come in, as will a lot of the residents down Swan Cot,
currently underserved at best when it comes to fiber.
They will have access to fiber now.
All of those developments along Swan Cot will benefit from having fiber there now.
It will also benefit from a two-lane county road with no shoulder to a five-lane boulevard.
But that is necessary so that we can move all of those individuals that live in the residential subdivisions out there
to and from potentially Mazda, Toyota, Eli Lilly, eventually Polaris and others in that area.
That housing is generally intended for.
Obviously, anybody can move out there.
But if you're looking to shorten your commute, these locations are absolutely the closest that you're going to get.
So really appreciate that fact.
And I hope the citizens of Huntsville understand that even those that may not like the idea of a TIF,
that you can't have it both ways.
If you want infrastructure to outpace your development, this is the perfect way in this particular case to make it happen.
We've got some other developments further out, but we are taking care of their infrastructure ahead of time as well.
But this provides the financing base to make sure that it's done in a large scale where development is really exploding.
So I want to thank you for that.
I also want to, on behalf of my constituents that have complained for as long as I've been in office about Exit 3
and how tough it is to navigate, particularly going south after heading from downtown Huntsville toward Decatur,
taking that exit and being stuck there for a long time trying to make a left.
So I know there'll be some additional movements that have to be made, but that will be taken care of.
And on their behalf, thank you.
Greatly appreciate it.
And I would say that with the relocation of County Line Road, since it's no longer going to be marking the county line,
I think Shane Davis Boulevard is a perfect name.
I believe this council has a rule and you better stick to it.
But that's all, Madam President.
I do want to bring up, Council Member, a good point if I may, Madam President.
So to the general public for TIF districts, you know, it allows us to advance infrastructure.
In this one, it's utilities and it's roads and it's elementary school and it's going to entice and induce.
And it's one of the reasons we've got the largest project in the state's history at $6 billion willing to come into this district.
It allows it to pay for itself.
We are not taking anything away from our multiple capital plans that every part of this community's got needs.
We're a growing community.
But that new tax base in the future will get spread throughout the city.
So, you know, this is a short window that we're going to capture some property taxes that's now going to produce three to seven X annually that comes back in this general fund that will be spread and used annually throughout every one of your districts.
So to me, it's like planting a new orchard.
It will bear a lot of fruit that will get spread throughout this community.
Thank you. Any other comments?
The public hearing is now closed.
Again, there will be no action taken on this.
The resolution will come to us with the final plan on October 8th.
Yes, ma'am.
That's when we will consider it.
Thank you, Mr. Davis, for your good work on this.
Thank you, councilmembers.
We'll now move on to public hearings to be set.
We have several. We ask for your indulgence while we go through these.
10A is a resolution to declare a public nuisance located at 3200 Tucker Drive, Northwest.
Councilor Bamford set a date for when objections will be heard.
Is there a motion to set the date for September 24, 2026?
Second.
Motion for Mr. Kling, second for Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
I oppose.
The motion carries.
10B is a resolution to set a public hearing on the zoning of 536.68 acres of land lying on the east of US Highway 72 East and north and south of Little Cove Road to residents one and residents two districts and introduction of an ordinance pertaining to the same.
Is there a motion to set the hearing for the October 22nd, 2026 regular council meeting?
So moved.
Motion for Mr. Kling, second for Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
I oppose.
The motion carries.
10C is a resolution to set a public hearing on the zoning of 3.07 acres of land lying on the west of Dupree Worthy Road, north and south of US Highway 72 West Highway Business C4 District and introduction of an ordinance pertaining to the same.
Is there a motion to set a hearing for October 22nd, 2026 regular council meeting?
So moved.
Second.
Who made the motion?
Mr. Meredith, second by Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
I oppose.
The motion carries.
10D is a resolution to set a public hearing on the zoning of 1.14 acres of land lying on the north of Countess Road west of Jack Jim Drive to residents one district and the introduction of an ordinance pertaining to the same.
Is there a motion to set it for October 22, 2026 regular council meeting?
So moved.
Motion for Mr. Little, second by the chair.
All in favor, please indicate.
I oppose.
The motion carries.
10E is a resolution to set a public hearing on the rezoning of 29.291.30 acres of land lying on the west of County Line Road south of I-565 from Highway Business C4 District to commercial industrial park district and introduction of an ordinance pertaining to the same.
Is there a motion to set for the October 22, 2026 regular council meeting?
So moved.
Second.
Motion for Mr. Meredith, second by Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
I oppose.
The motion carries.
This brings us to agenda related public comments.
This portion of the meeting is reserved for persons wishing to address the council on matters relating to the specific content of items on the meeting agenda.
Two people have signed up to speak.
When your name is called, please approach the microphone, state your name, home address, and city of residence.
Each speaker may address the council for three minutes.
Speakers shall refrain from entering into dialogue with council members or city staff and from making comments regarding good name and character of any individual.
The first person to sign up is Susan Higgins.
Ms. Higgins here.
Who will be followed by Forest Satterfield.
Good evening.
My name is Susan Higgins.
I live at 1127 Locust Avenue in Huntsville.
I want to first thank council member Meredith for introducing ordinance 26836 to remove the tax on hearing aids.
It is much appreciated and I hope that all of city council will support this.
I've been wearing hearing aids since I was five years old.
I won't tell you my age, but suffice it to say that's decades of experience.
For most of our time I wore two hearing aids.
So it's double the cost and double the tax.
Hearing loss is incredibly isolating.
People with hearing loss rely on hearing aids and other technology to be independent and to participate in their communities, to work, to go to school, and to testify at city council meetings.
For most of us, a hearing aid is not a luxury or a want.
It is a fundamental necessity for quality of life.
Hearing aids last about three to five years on average, so they're not a long-term investment.
Many people with hearing loss experience decline over time so that replacements are needed sooner than that five-year frame.
Hearing aids are not covered by Medicare and most insurance companies.
It is an out-of-pocket expense and in this case it's taxed.
They range in price from $99 to over $8,000.
I just ordered a new hearing aid on Tuesday.
It will cost me $1,950.
The tax on that is $78 and that's small in terms of the bigger price, but it's also a big strain, especially these days.
I am paying a tax for something I fundamentally need.
There's no choice.
If I want to be independent and participate in my community, this is the only hearing aid that works with the technology that I need.
For many in our community, you are believing them of a tax burden of between $20 and $40.
There's small loss of revenue for the city and a major relief for many of our citizens who have retired or are on limited incomes.
I would like each of you to consider that continuing this tax, you are taxing an item that is absolutely necessary and absolutely critical for some of our citizens.
It is certainly enough of a budget consideration that next time I'll drive up to Madison City to buy a hearing aid where they have repealed the tax.
Many cities across the state are doing this and I hope that Huntsville would be a leader.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Ms. Higgins, the next person to speak will be Forrest Satterfield.
Is Mr. Satterfield here?
Forrest Satterfield?
He is not here.
Then we will, that will, oh.
Hey y'all.
Your name and address for the record.
Forrest Satterfield, Constellation, so that's 740 Constellation Place Drive over behind the VBC.
Very good, thank you sir.
I should have gone before Susan, she did a much better job at that.
What I will say is that hearing loss is something that is not something that people choose to have.
And if we were to tax these people, the total income that I am aware of is between $100,000 and $150,000.
That benefit to the city is small and yet as Susan so eloquently put, is great to the individuals.
And so I would advocate that we take away this tax so that it does not impact people who are in addition to paying for these hearing aids,
paying for the batteries, paying for the procedures, paying for the continued upkeep.
You know, as was once again said so well by Susan, these are things that really do add up for the people of Huntsville.
Thank you.
Thank you sir.
Now that does conclude our agenda related comments.
We will move on to the Mayor's comments.
Thank you Madam President.
Just a reminder to all, tomorrow the 9-11 ceremonies start at 746 A.M.
Station 1 on Clinton Avenue and everybody is invited, all the public is invited to come out.
This is the 25th anniversary and it is very hard to get your head around it.
The first time I was there was about 25 years ago was when the 9-11 tragedy happened when people rammed airplanes into buildings in New York City and Washington D.C.
and crashed a plane in Pennsylvania.
It's one of those things that our country looks back on.
For 25 years we've looked back on this and this ceremony has been taking place for 25 years so that we can remember those and memorialize those who lost their lives in that.
So we will be there, there will be a good group there and we would encourage all to come out and if you can't come out, take a few minutes out right around between 740 and 750
and just say a little prayer for those who lost their lives on that tragic day.
Going from that news to we have Jazz in the Parks which is Sunday night.
Last Sunday there was a huge crowd down there by Mayor's count.
We had 45,000 people in Big Spring Park and it was really some great music, great crowds, even as hot as it was.
But it really still turned out a great crowd and I think everybody enjoyed it coming out and it's going to be happening every Sunday through this month.
So come out and enjoy it. It's at the back of the Art Museum at Big Spring Park.
And finally we want to say congratulations to the Huntsville Area Chamber of Commerce.
They put on the Paracycling World Championship this last weekend.
It was hot and it was very hot out there.
I was out there Friday night and had to drink lots of water after I got finished to stay hydrated.
And to the crew at the chamber, you showed what troopers you were.
You hung in there for the whole Friday, Saturday, Sunday and Monday.
And it was, you know, we showed off our city very well.
The people who were here were from all over the world.
It was an international crowd and they couldn't say enough nice things about the city except where it was hot.
But to each of you, especially to the chamber, thank you for the work that you did.
Thank you for what you did for our community.
As I told someone, I said, you know, this really is an exercise of showing that we have a heart and a big, big heart.
So thank you.
Thank you, Mayor Battle.
We'll go on to Councilmember Cummings and hear first from Councilmember Bill Cleen.
Thank you, Madam President.
One of the concerns I want to express, especially as we start pivoting into a new fiscal year,
is what seems to have been a pattern which unfortunately had taken place in numerous streets,
I think not just within the district I represent, but I think in other streets that were being resurfaced in other parts of the city.
There's a process where streets, for example, let me use Holiday Drive as an example, is prepped before resurfacing takes place.
The contractor and the people come in, they kind of mill the asphalt down, they fix the curb and have everything all prepped up.
And then there's a second contractor that comes in who basically takes over and does the fun part,
laying out the asphalt with the results that people like to see.
There's been a process, it's been a problem rather, where Holiday Drive, for example, spent at least seven months where it was torn up
and the residents on it had to live on it, go through the dust, slow down.
Occasionally there would be a windshield that would get hit with the pea gravel.
And they would have to wait and we would still not get a satisfactory response from the public works director about when the asphalt contractor would be coming.
I'm using as an example, Harwood, Holiday, similar example, had a long waiting period.
Homewood Drive basically went through being milled in the fall and then not being resurfaced until the wintertime came.
Eustis, it's still like a work in progress.
But I'd like to see if there's some way we can either get with this public works director or whoever takes charge to have something lined up where the contractors know
and they are bound by contract and whatever it takes to make it happen where there's a reasonable period of time where the prepping is done
and then after the prepping is done, shortly thereafter the asphalting would take place.
By contrast, I hate to say this, but in our backyard over here on Church Street, we had something similar where it was milled, it was prepped.
And then very shortly after, then the asphalt would come in and that would minimize the inconvenience that the citizens had to go through.
But I think this is a problem.
We've got a new fiscal year coming up and I think that's a good time just to get a process in place, make sure it's going to be followed, make sure that if somebody's going to do business with the city,
that they have a certain window of time that they're supposed to do their job.
And then the next contractor has a window where he's supposed to do his job and follow through because these resurfacing, we like doing them because they're supposed to be a benefit for our neighborhoods and for the people who live on them.
But for many of the people there, very, very unhappy and a lot of inconvenience that took place for those folks.
So just something I wanted to throw out for Public Works to do during the upcoming, hopefully the new fiscal year.
That's all, Madam President. Oh, one other, no, that's all. Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Kling. We'll now hear from Councilmember David Little.
Thank you, Madam President. I'd like to thank our Engineering, Public Works, Traffic Department and HPD on being responsive to some citizen concerns these last few weeks.
And then also, most everybody knows next month is Community Planning Month, National Community Planning Month.
And accordingly, we're going to be doing a meeting out in the Hampton Cove area mid to late October to talk about the good things we're working on out there.
That's all I've got. Thank you.
Thank you, Mr. Wood.
It was a pleasure to have the opportunity to go to the Brown and be involved in the groundbreaking ceremony at Westmorelanding,
which is a $2.2 billion investment in Western Huntsville.
And it's going to be in retail, restaurants, gathering spaces, and most importantly, a variety of housing options that support residents in that area at every stage of their life.
I also had the opportunity to participate in the medal award ceremony during the UCI Para Cycling World Championships last weekend.
It was a unique opportunity that I am grateful to the Chamber and the Research Park Board for inviting me to serve in that function,
which was an opportunity to not only meet but interact with some truly wonderful athletes from all over the world.
I will be hosting a community forum on flock cameras here in the council chambers next Wednesday, September 16th at 4 p.m.
The guests will be HPD Chief Kirk Giles and North Alabama Multi-Agency Crime Center or NAMAC Director Kurt Worsick.
And the public, as always when it comes to the forums I host, is invited to be here,
hear from the issue or subject matter experts, and ask any questions that they might have of those experts.
So I look forward to a very entertaining and informative forum next week.
And I certainly hope that the myriad of people that have been pounding me and I'm sure my colleagues on flock cameras actually show up
and on the record have their questions answered by those experts.
I'd also like to announce the District 5 Town Hall next Thursday, September 17th.
That will be at 6 p.m. at the New Hope Cumberland Presbyterian Church on Wall Street in Madison, Alabama.
Technically it's Madison, Alabama. That's a mailing address, but it's definitely the city of Huntsville.
And we will delve a little bit deeper into some of the development that will be happening in their neighborhoods.
Finally, brings me to something I have been pondering for quite a while.
And it's a difficult decision that I've had to make because I know that certain people are going to paint me as being difficult.
They're going to classify me or call me a bomb thrower.
But after much prayer, I think it's important to hold this council to following the rules that we are supposed to be operating under.
A special session of the council was called by President Robinson for September 18th.
And it was published on the council agenda page of the city of Huntsville's website for a presentation of the FY 27 annual budget by the administration.
I was prepared to hear that presentation and at that time offer any amendments I or my colleagues might have.
However, I was informed by President Robinson and an email to the entire council that after meeting with the administration,
to review the reorganization chart in the fire and police pay raise,
she believed it would not be appropriate to hold a special session to review the budget and other matters.
And as a result, the council would hold a work session on September 18th to provide an opportunity to review the budget and the impact of the reorganization and raises on the budget.
She mentioned later in that email that she did not think we would rush through action or should rush through action on the budget or the new staff structure.
This explanation left me not being able to understand the full extent of what was to be presented at this work session.
She had evidently just decided to switch from a special session.
Indeed, what the.
This was not according to state law in Alabama.
There was no mention in the email I received concerning that this council needed to make sure that we were fully transparent with the public and the need for a careful review of public transparency.
I believe all my constituents know that I am certainly an advocate for transparency for public matters, all public matters,
as well as anyone who knows me is well aware that I play by the rules and I insist that others play by the rules.
Perhaps transparency that she has talked about should begin with this council or at least myself.
Because I cannot speak for my other colleagues here because I'm not privy to what conversations they had with the president.
From my understanding of the proper rules for conducting business and the Alabama law,
I do not believe the president of the council has the authority to arbitrarily change a called and published special session of the council to a work session with other members of the council.
And as far as I am aware, and certainly not the opportunity to vote on the matter, if this was done from some sense of personal power or authority,
I wish I which I don't believe the council president has and without following the rules or caring about my rights or the rights of other council members,
it is a despicable act to have a special session of the council.
As a result, I am formally requesting that the city's legal department issue a written legal opinion regarding whether the council president possesses the unilateral authority under Alabama code section 11-43-50
and the Huntsville City Council rules to change a properly called and published special session into a non-voting work session over the formal objection of council member.
And whether doing so complies with the public's decision to change the law or the law itself is a question of the council's decision to change the law.
I would like to request that the council change a properly called and published special session into a non-voting work session over the formal objection of council member.
And whether doing so complies with the public notice requirements of the Alabama Open Meetings Act.
And I'd like that by close of business on September 17th.
And while I know it cannot be had by next week, I would also request an inquiry of the attorney general's opinion on this matter.
Thank you.
Mr. Riley, will you please comply with that? You will comply with that.
Thank you, sir. And we can have that by September 17th.
Thank you, sir.
Well, now we will hear from Ms. Watkins.
Good evening, everyone.
Last Thursday, I had the pleasure of going to Harris Home for Children.
The Leo family Vulcan Corporation and other community members and volunteers came out for a ribbon cutting.
The Leo family remodeled the gym and Vulcan went in and painted and bought furniture and decorated.
And when I tell you it was so overwhelming to see the community come together to refurbish this facility, to make it look like a home for the residents.
So I want to especially thank the Leo family and I want to thank Vulcan as well and the other community members that attended.
Andy Warhol exhibit.
I had the pleasure of going to CNN last Friday.
If you have not went to see it, you need to.
My favorite painting is one of Merlin Monroe.
And I was just excited to go there and see it.
Today, I had the pleasure of attending a meeting at Happy Health and the administrator of the Health Resources and Services Administration.
Mr. Tom Ingalls was in town to award them a six hundred and fifty thousand dollar grant that they applied for.
Representative Holl was there.
Commissioner Edwards as well as Congressman Dale Strong.
It was a really big deal for Happy Health who are investing in our community and individuals who do not have insurance.
I was very excited about that.
Thank you, Susan Higgins, for sharing your story.
And and I truly appreciate you being brave enough to come to the microphone and talk about your hearing aids.
And I definitely support this.
I support the effort to eliminate the tax.
Some people cannot afford this.
And I think this is something that we should support.
But I'm going to record saying I support it.
Also today, I had the pleasure this morning of wishing our best girlfriend, Tony Terrell, fond farewell on her last day on her radio show.
And it was so nice to see all the people that came out.
She has so many flowers.
I don't know how she's going to get a mental car.
And she had all kinds of treats.
And it was just great to see Tony.
We had her here a couple of weeks ago to recognize her for 20 years of service.
In the community, we had no idea that her time was coming to an end.
But I didn't tell Tony goodbye.
I told her until what's next, because Tony has a lot to offer this community.
I want to thank Miss Kathy Miller and your staff.
I want to thank the Madison County Commission, MPO, as well as anyone in the city of Huntsville that had any of the best services that they could offer.
And I want to thank you for that.
And your staff.
I want to thank the Madison County Commission MPO, as well as anyone in the city of Huntsville.
They had anything to do with getting the approval for the safety measures that salty bottom.
Thank you so much.
And David and I want to email with you immediately after the meeting.
You jumped on top of it.
So thank you so much for that.
I'm going to be on my town hall
is going to be on the fourteenth
at five thirty at the Shirley
Center. Please come out if you
have any questions. Comments or
if you just want to know what's
going on in the community. Um
twenty the mayor talked about
nine eleven and twenty five
years ago at nine oh three AM.
I think all of us were watching
from the first one to the
second. Second tower was hit at
nine oh three AM and my cousin
got to see her again. Um what
what was so crazy about it? Um
she lived in New York so we
would go there in the summers
or they would come here. She
was here the whole month of
July. We got to spend some time
with her. We got to connect with
her but the memories are still
there and it's hard. She had
one child and he's really been
struggling with losing his
mother. He never got to say
goodbye. He was thirteen. So
don't ever forget nine eleven
because somebody somewhere is
still struggling with that
grief. Thank you. Thank you
Miss Watkins. We're sorry for
your loss. Thank you for that
memory. Uh we have a long
awaited ribbon cutting coming
up next week on Tuesday
September fifteenth. We will
cut the ribbon for the
Sandor Moon Center. We have
been working with Sandor Moon
family to make sure that they
could be present and we finally
have found that date and we
look forward to welcoming them
to celebrate Sandor Moon's life
and to open this facility. The
ribbon cutting will take place
at ten o'clock. It will be
immediately followed by tours
until twelve and then we will
also have tours from four to
seven in the afternoon. Um this
is just an exceptional facility
and we look forward to opening
it to the public. We will also
have a day of celebration.
We will have a celebration on
Saturday uh uh September twenty
sixth. Uh Arts Huntsville has
scheduled an entire day of
performances on the moon stage
and then the first performance
is actually scheduled for
October first and it will be
the brass band of Huntsville.
So lots of good things will be
happening there. That concludes
council comments. We will move
on to the finance committee
report. Fourteen A is a
resolution authorizing
expenditures for payment. Mr.
Meredith, would you like to
make that motion? I move for
motion and approval of
expenditures in the amount of
forty two million three hundred
forty one thousand seven
hundred twenty three dollars
and seventeen cents. Second by
the chair. All in favor please
indicate. Aye. Opposed? Motion
carries. Fourteen B is. Before
we move on um finance director
Penny Smith wanted me to make a
couple of announcements. Um one
that the budget books were made
available to the council
yesterday or at the dais uh if
you didn't pick them up
yesterday and they uh were
available to the council
committee. Um they will be
available next Friday at the
budget meeting. Uh um and um
it was decided to divide back
out the agency appropriations
and they are now in a separate
book that has been provided um
and both the documents will be
placed on the city website this
evening. Um and to let her or
the council know that they are
in the process of getting
those documents. Um the budget
uh meeting for next Friday at
eleven AM and the second
reading in the budget uh will
be voted on at the council
regular council meeting on the
twenty fourth and it is that
meeting where the capital uh
the nineteen ninety and twenty
fourteen capital plans will be
uh presented and we'll get
documentation on that at that
meeting. Uh and the next
reading is the district ordinance
approving appropriations goods
or services for district two
council improvement funds.
Second. Mr. Little second from
Ms. Watkins. Mr. Little would
you like to share with us what
we're doing? Yes ma'am. Thank
you. This is a ten thousand
dollar appropriation for the
eighth street community formerly
known as 305 H Street. It's a
group home for adults that
don't really either have family
or don't qualify for government
services. It's a wonderful
organization and they had a big
impact on people that they were
able to get a job. So that's
what we want to do. Thank you.
Any questions for Mr. Little?
All in favor please indicate
aye. Opposed? The motion
carries. Fourteen E is an
ordinance approving appropriations
goods or services for the
district four council
improvement funds. There are
motions. So move. Motion from
Mr. Kling. Second from Mr. Little.
Um Mr. Kling. Uh madam president
this would be used for helping
to relieve uh suffering for uh
dogs that are owned by homeless
individuals. This includes
primarily food and also
medical care. Thank you. Any
questions or comments? All in
favor please indicate aye.
Opposed? The motion carries.
Fourteen D. Fourteen D is an
ordinance approving
appropriations goods or
services for district five
council improvement funds. Is
there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve. Second.
Second from Ms. Watkins. Mr.
Meredith. Yes ma'am. Um this is
a five thousand dollar
allocation to no more dirty
incorporated uh which is a
Christian based organization to
fund youth scholarships,
mentorship initiatives and
educational enrichment programs
within the city of Huntsville.
Any comments or questions? All
in favor please indicate aye.
Opposed? The motion carries. We
have no board appointments to be
voted on but we have a lot of
board appointment nominations
and our bylaws require us that
they be read. This these are for
nomination only. They will be
considered at the September 24
regular council meeting. 16A is
a nomination to reappoint
Geraldine Tibbs to the
beautification board, place 13,
her current seat for a three
year term to expire September
30, 2029. 16B is a nomination
to reappoint Jane Tippett to
the beautification board, place
14, her current seat for a
three year term to expire
September 30, 2029. 16C is a
nomination to reappoint Ginger
Young to the beautification
board, place 16, her current
seat for a three year term to
expire Sept. 30, 2029. 16D is a
nomination to reappoint Amanda
Burns to the beautification
board, place 17, her current
seat for a three year term to
expire September 30, 2029. 16F
is a nomination to reappoint
Sara Smith to the Beret
for three year term to expire October 1, 2029.
16-G is nomination to reappoint Theresa Derbro
to the Burik Memorial Committee,
place four, her current seat for a three year term
to expire October 1, 2029.
16-H is a nomination
to reappoint Brian Daniels to the Burik Memorial Committee.
Place seven, his current seat for a three year term
to expire October 1, 2029.
16-I is a nomination to appoint Helen Lein
to the Burik Memorial Committee,
place 10, to fill a vacancy
due to the resignation of Cindy Griner
for the remainder of a vacant three-year term
to expire October 1, 2028.
16J is a nomination to appoint Linda Foulkes
to the Beret Memorial Committee,
place 11 to the seat previously held by Dawn Pompeli
for a three-year term to expire October 1, 2029.
16K is a nomination to appoint Cody Hogwood
to the City Tree Commission,
to the seat previously held by Lisa Gardner
for a two-year term to expire October 8, 2028.
16L is a nomination to reappoint Janice Vaughn
to the Human Relations Commission,
place three her current seat for a four-year term
to expire September 30, 2030.
16M is a nomination to reappoint Barbara Hughes
to the Human Relations Commission,
place for her current seat for four year term
to expire September 30, 2030.
16N is a nomination to reappoint Tammy Hammond's figures
to the Human Relations Commission
place five her current seat for a four-year term
to expire September 30, 2030.
Are there any nominations from the floor?
Hearing none, we'll move on.
17, Huntsville utility items.
17A is a resolution authorizing,
just so everybody knows what we're doing here,
the city is required to approve
the Huntsville utility budgets.
There are separate budgets for electric, water, and gas.
So that's what you're going to be hearing here.
17A is a resolution authorizing the mayor
to approve budget work orders and project work orders
for new construction, for system improvements,
capital projects, including material purchasing,
and outside services, labor, transportation,
and other expenses as outlined in the budget
for the water department for the fiscal year 2027
at a total estimated cost of $17,051,705.
Is there a motion to approve?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Erwin.
Second from Mr. Kling.
And with us tonight, we have Mr. Wes Kelly
to make this presentation.
Welcome, Mr. Kelly.
Thank you, Madam President.
And yes, you have important items in front of you
and you have moved on the water.
I'm also going to, if it's okay,
present on electric and gas all at the same time.
Madam President, can't do that.
Well, you know what, we just...
Council members, would you have any objection
if we were to have the presentation on all these items
and then we will consider each one separately?
I think the motion needs to be to suspend the rules.
Am I not correct, Mr. Riley?
I would ask which rule you're citing.
The one that precludes cross discussion of items,
not being able to discuss item 17B
when we're talking about 17A.
Okay, is this a local rule or is this a Robert's Rules Board?
Robert's.
I'm unaware of a local rule
that requires the one for our council.
So if it isn't specified in our bylaws,
doesn't it defer to Robert's Rules?
Well, if it's not covered by that, correct,
and that's still an interpretation.
Well, if you can't identify a bylaw rules
that supersedes Robert's,
then Robert's is the rule in charge, correct?
Well, actually, you could argue it several different ways.
The way our rule is written is our rules abide by us,
and if our rules don't provide any guidance,
then you look to Robert's Rules of Order.
Isn't that what I just said?
Well, I think we're looking at things in a different way.
Madam, I could present just the water if that's so.
To simplify things, if you would not mind doing that.
Absolutely, and at the end, I can cover any broader topics.
Thank you.
Okay, well, very good.
So for the water capital items, and it is true,
the City Council has,
state law provides statutory requirements
that City Council approve new construction improvements
and equipment related to your municipal utilities.
Just a reminder of the water system,
we have three surface water treatment plants
and one groundwater plant.
The three surface water plants
are aligned along the Tennessee River.
The groundwater plant is at the Lincoln Dallas facility
in the middle of Huntsville.
And you see we've got about 1500 miles of water main
and almost 40 reservoirs and storage tanks
scattered throughout the service area.
Now, this just shows in general, the customer growth,
and you see customer growth in water
has been quite slow in 2025.
Part of that is because the water meters do not,
as we've set more and more apartments in this community,
there's usually one water meter per complex,
rather than one water meter per unit.
And so you see the water growth has been quite slow,
actually, over this last year.
It's been trending down for a few years.
Water sales revenue, you see the big jump in 2024
related to the rate increase
that the council authorized at that time.
And otherwise, water sales are pretty constant.
No big changes there.
You have the resolutions in front of you.
I wanted to highlight three in particular.
One is the Eastern Connector.
This is a large water transmission main,
which is going to help us get water
from the Southeast Water Treatment Plant,
which currently pushes water up,
of course, into the Hampton Cove area
and then also across into South Huntsville.
This will allow us to branch that yet another direction,
go up through Hampton Cove, through the McMillan Cove area,
hitting Highway 72, and then ultimately,
not only helping support development on the east side,
but to tie into an existing large transmission main
along Highway 72 that pushes water north
into the Chase-Winchester area,
where there's been a significant amount of growth
and impacts specifically the Chase Industrial Park.
So this is helping support growth activities
both on the east side of the system
and the north side of the system.
So this is a very expensive project
for a water transmission main,
but our crews are ready to get started on it,
and we will have to cross the Flint River
at a couple of points,
and that's one of the reasons for the cost.
The Southeast Water Treatment Plant upgrades,
this is the same plant I was talking about,
the one that's down in Grand, Alabama.
This is to add large water pumps
that will increase both the redundancy
and in total pumpage capacity available out of that pump
to ensure that we can get 24 million gallons
a day production.
Resiliently, right now, if we have a pump failure,
then that plant is compromised.
We wanna be able to operate that plant
in a more resilient manner.
And then finally, the one that I wanted to highlight
with you is Water AMI.
This is a fairly modest project.
It is providing for automated meter reading
within the Limestone County portion of our water system,
helps us reduce windshield time quite a bit,
and also gets us going with the new software
and technology associated with this,
so that once this is done,
we can move into the Madison County portion of our area,
starting with the largest water meters,
and then eventually working our way down.
I would love to install Water AMI across the board
because I think it has significant benefits
for leak detections for our customers.
You know, if that meter's been spinning
for 24 consecutive hours, it could send a notification
telling the customer, hey, you probably have a water leak.
I would love to be able to do that.
Unfortunately, it's fairly expensive,
and we have a lot of major projects
we need to accomplish in the water system.
And to be quite blunt, we just don't have the funds
to accommodate a full AMI deployment right now,
but we're gonna dip our toe in the water
and get started with this Limestone County implementation,
where I think we're gonna get the most value.
Your resolutions are a little bit less than this
because you approve both budget work orders,
which are items which are spent within the fiscal year,
and you also approve project work orders
which span multiple fiscal years.
But obviously we have to get authorization
to build the whole project,
even though it's gonna take multiple years.
This gives you an idea.
This is our five-year capital plan in water.
Now obviously FY27 is the one that matters.
Some of these items have been approved
on previous project work orders.
FY28, 29, 30, and 31 are planning purposes,
but it's just to give you an idea
of how things are laying out
and where we see things going in the future
on the water system related to its infrastructure needs.
This is recurring capital,
meaning this is items we spend every year.
Transportation is a big hit on this.
Operation and maintenance materials
is what you would imagine, pipes and valves and fittings.
And then general development and extension
is also what you might imagine.
That's what we need to invest
just to connect new customers and make magic happen.
It also helps with road relocation projects and whatnot.
And then down below you see where the money comes from.
Pay as you go is meaning that's cash
that we're spending.
Transfers, we don't have any this year.
Reimbursements is where we're getting money from the state
related to state highway projects.
We're on the water system, they do pay for that.
And then you see system development fees
is money coming from developers
that are helping offset the cost of new construction
for their development projects.
Then you see state revolving loan fund.
We anticipate getting a little bit more
out of state revolving loan fund and then stopping.
And then you see other borrowing proceeds.
We have some previously approved bond issuance
that we're gonna finish in 2027,
but we do anticipate probably coming back
and talking to you about additional borrowings necessary
in the water system in future years.
Again, the water system is probably the one
that is the most budget challenged.
Y'all were very understanding on the rate increase approved.
But as you know, that was to approve
the 20 year capital plan.
That 20 year capital plan we are advancing on,
we are making that happen.
But we've also seen significant inflation
in material and equipment during that period of time.
So we're having to make that work.
So, but we'll come back and talk about future borrowings
when that's necessary.
That's for future fiscal years.
So just to give you an idea,
we keep up with this every month on Huntsville Utilities.
Wanted to share it with you.
This is average residential consumption of 4,100 gallons
at residential rates compared to nearby water systems.
You see Huntsville Utilities, the second lowest.
I can tell you, I expect when I come back here next year,
I think we will be the lowest.
Questions or comments regarding the water budget
for Mr. Kelly?
Any questions?
Mr. Kling?
I'm not sure what comes from you
and what comes from Public Works.
But we were having a problem with rusted groundwater
in some of the older neighborhoods,
such as Low Mill, Merrimack.
Is that your ballpark or does that go to Public Works?
Yes, sir.
No, that's us.
So we need to be advancing out on our cast iron replacement.
That's the older pipes that are in the older parts of town.
And so we've been identifying areas
and we have money set aside in this year's budget
to continue that project.
I think about a million bucks.
We need to get that up to a bigger number.
Actually, maybe a little less this year.
We need to, that's one of those items
that as we finish these major capital projects,
like the Eastern Connector and others,
that money will then ship back on these pipe replacements.
But if people are getting brown water,
we need to address that.
We need to get those pipes replaced.
Okay, it's pretty vocal over in the Low Mill neighborhood
if you look into that.
Very good, thank you.
We'll tend to that quickly.
Mr. Meredith.
Yes, sir, ma'am, thank you, sir.
If you could address,
I guess we're sticking to the budget here,
but are there any budgetary outlays to
correct or accelerate some of the downfalls,
not the best word, with the water quality reports
that were recently sent out to folks?
Not quite sure.
There was no deficiencies in the water quality report.
Certain elements were not necessarily tested
at the frequency that some of my constituents
have expressed concern with to me.
I believe lead was one of them and chlorine was another.
That the frequency that was tested by HU
wasn't what was normal nationally
with other water providers.
Well, we'll need to, we follow all of the Alabama
Department of Environmental Management's requirements.
Matter of fact, all of our,
we received the Surface Water Plan of the Year Award,
the Ground Water Plan of the Year Award,
and the Distribution System of the Year Award
from our regional area in Mississippi and Alabama.
So I would need to know specifically
what items they're citing because ADEM has not made us
aware that we're deficient in any category
that I'm aware of.
And Mr. Meredith, I would caution you,
we need to restrict this to discussions about the budget.
Well, I asked if there were any budgetary,
if they were gonna spend money to do those.
That was the way I put it.
We are straying into an area outside of the budget.
Well, Brown Water is outside the budget too, okay?
But he tied it to the budget, I tied it to the budget.
I asked specifically if there was money going to be spent
in order to increase the testing.
The answer was no, because we,
I'm not aware that that's a problem.
HU follows exactly what the state law is
and you have been a recipient of multiple awards.
So if that answers that question perfectly,
I will follow up with the folks that have reached out to me
with those concerns.
But from what you have described,
there is no need for money to be spent to do things
in excess of what you are required to by the state
of which you are an award-winning person.
Yes, sir.
And I believe we have a meeting coming up
where our director of water operations
and our manager of water supply is,
we're working to schedule a meeting with you
and your constituents to talk about that very issue.
Yes, sir, thank you.
So we'll look forward to having that meeting.
And on behalf of my constituents,
thank you for addressing that.
Yes, sir.
Are there any other questions regarding the water budget?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
The motion carries.
17B is a resolution authorizing the mayor
to approve budget work orders and project work orders
for new construction, for system improvements,
and capital projects, including material purchasing,
outside services, labor, transportation,
and other expenses outlined in the budget
for the gas department for the fiscal year 2027
at a total estimated cost of $15,867,500.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion for Mr. Little.
Second.
Second for Mr. Kling.
And again, this is specific to the gas budget.
All right, well, our gas system, you see the map there.
It's a little more of an ink block
when you look at the map in terms of how it's been developed
over the years.
We received flow of natural gas through two major pipelines,
the Southern Natural Pipeline and the Allaton Pipeline.
And we've got five gate stations where we,
the gate stations is where we interconnect
with those major, those regional pipelines.
You see about 1,681 miles of distribution
and you see the flows there.
We also do have gas storage in Louisiana,
about a third of our winter capacity we have
in salt dome storage in Louisiana.
So we've got a pretty complex arrangement
for risk mitigation on gas.
You see the gas customer counts are growing
at about a 2% clip.
The revenue has increased as industrial activity
has increased in the Greenbrier area a bit
and then otherwise it's been weather dependent.
So the three major capital projects
that I wanted to highlight on your list for you
in this budget is first Providence, Maine.
There's a 18 inch welded steel gas main
located currently under Providence, Maine.
We would like to relocate that to an area
that is less densely populated.
And we're working now to find that route
so that we can do that.
You see that's a $5 million project.
We've been talking about this one for a while,
happy to move out and get this taken care of.
Honestly, it's perfectly fine where it is,
but it just feels better to get it
into a less populated area as Providence
has continued to develop the way that it has.
Furthermore, we're looking at building out
a high pressure gas system into the Greenbrier area.
This is for the Eli Lilly side
and really the area you were just describing
for your TIF district.
This is to extend natural gas services
into that area satisfactory to meet that growing space.
And then also we have a series of projects identified
to help on the north end of the system.
If you remember that ink blot map,
there were several tentacles to the north.
We want to over time connect those, loop those,
and build that into a looped, more resilient system.
So we've been working on this for a number of years.
We're gonna continue to work on this for a number of years
to build that system out.
This is the five-year plan on gas.
It's much smaller, much more modest
in terms of the five-year vision on gas.
It's a smaller utility, more straightforward.
So this has both the non-recurring, the reoccurring,
and the funding sources, which are all rates.
They're all cash.
There's no additional funding sources envisioned
on the gas system for the next five years.
Questions for Mr.
Were you finished?
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I forgot this slide.
So this is our rate comparison on gas.
And you see we're generally on that bottom end
of the equation.
Gas does tend to bounce around more.
Our rates are, we have a very traditional rate structure.
Several of our peer utilities have gas rates
that change monthly based on gas fuel costs.
We've not adopted that yet.
That's something that we could
and perhaps should adopt in the future.
But right now we just have a traditional fixed rate.
Any questions or comments from Mr. Kelly
regarding the gas budget?
Or should I say volumetric rate?
Thank you, Mr. Kelly.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Motion carries.
And then finally, 17C is a resolution
authorizing the mayor to approve budget work orders
and project work orders for new construction
for system improvements, capital projects,
including material purchasing, outside services,
labor, transportation, other expenses,
as outlined in the budget electric department
for the fiscal year 2027,
a total estimated cost of $56,232,200.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion from Mr. Little, second from the chair.
Mr. Kelly.
Yeah, so the water system is basically Madison County
and you see it dip down into Marshall County as well.
We're tied into five TVA transmission lines.
We received that power at 15 places around Madison County.
Quite a bit more, you see 5,000 miles of distribution
scattered throughout that service area,
108 substations sprinkled all the way throughout the county.
And we draw your attention to the bottom
where renewable energy,
I'm gonna have separate slides on this,
but we are moving out in that space.
And that has turned out to be a good space
for Huntsville Utilities to be in.
Related to the electric department is the fiber department.
So the fiber infrastructure is part of the electric assets.
Since 2016, we've now built out over 1300 miles of fiber.
That's a lot.
You see the service area there.
Of course, its primary purpose is to meet
Huntsville Utilities and City of Huntsville needs.
We also lease that fiber to Huntsville City Schools,
G-Fiber and a dozen or so other entities
that utilize that resource.
It generates about $11 million a year annually
that feeds back into the electric budget.
So I talked about renewables.
We have two major solar projects.
One is finished and one is underway.
The one that is finished is the Toyota site.
Since April of 2024, that has produced savings
of $8.1 million.
And that's not a we think it produced savings of.
That is comparing it to how much we would have paid TVA
each month for that power based on the current rates
compared to what we pay Toyota to Shusho,
the solar developer, for the same kilowatt hours.
So you see 2.7 million of that was through
the actual kilowatt hour energy sales.
The large majority of it, $5.4 million,
was peak reduction, meaning the solar panels
were producing when we set our peak demand from TVA.
And without getting too much in the weeds,
about half of our power bill to TVA
is assessed on the amount of energy we use
one hour per month.
Whatever that peak hour is of the month
establishes the peak demand.
And that is about half of our power bill to TVA.
So if we can shove that peak demand down,
and in this case by 30 megawatts,
that generates over this last, since April of 2024,
$5.4 million.
So the one that's underway, as you know,
is the Triana project that we're working on.
Roads are under construction, development's underway,
but really we're waiting on TVA to sign off
on the solar interconnect requirements
and other approvals that TVA has to give
so that that project can move forward.
So we're hopeful to get those back in the next few months
and that project can get significantly underway.
We do have a new program called Solar Connect.
This is a rooftop solar program.
As you see right now, if you can read that writing,
we have a whopping three customers on it.
It's going to get bigger.
I believe we have nine customers in the pipeline.
This is because TVA used to have a rooftop solar program
and they've been phasing it out.
This is Huntsville Utilities stepping up
with our own program to replace that program.
And we've actually got a nice video on our website
and good material out there.
So if any customers are interested
in a small scale rooftop solar program,
we do have something available to them now.
These are the overall numbers.
You see we're just a hair under 230,000 electric meters,
which that number's been growing quite a bit.
As you see in 2021, it was just over 200,000.
Now it's almost to 230,000.
So that number's been growing very rapidly.
And then you see the sales revenue.
Sales revenue is highly dependent on weather.
The three major projects I wanted to point out to you here,
the first one is the twofer.
The Elkton section and Northwest substations
are major substations where we tie
into TVA transmission systems.
You see both of those are quite expensive.
$13.6 million and $12.7 million.
This is to provide additional capacity
on the north end of Madison County,
where if anyone's driven to north end of Madison County,
you see subdivisions are going in like crazy.
So we need to make sure that we can keep up
with that load that's necessary
to support that customer base.
The Downtown Switchgear Revitalization
is a project I'm very excited about.
Thanks to the fact that we have our fiber network in place,
thanks to the fact we have our new system operations center
and our new SCADA system in place
and the technology associated with that,
and thanks to the fact that we have a lot of smart
and innovative people at Huntsville Utilities,
we're ready to install much more sophisticated
electronic intelligence out into the distribution system.
We're gonna start that in the downtown.
So there's a number of switches, manual switches,
which are down in vaults under the ground today.
We actually have to send people down
into those very constrained areas
with high voltage electricity
and ask them to do amazing things
to get the power back on if there's a problem.
This will allow that to happen remotely
or certainly above the vault
and allow that to happen electronically in real time
tied into our SCADA system.
So we see this starting in the downtown
and not stopping in the downtown.
There's other areas that we will continue to move out
as we continue to deploy this advanced switch technology
throughout our distribution network.
And then finally, I mentioned Project Gemini,
which is the Triana solar site.
Assuming that TVA gives its approvals,
which I don't expect they won't,
it just takes a little time to go through that process,
then we need to build a substation and a circuit
to connect that back into the Huntsville Utility system.
We expect to make money on that project
just like we made money on this project.
May not be quite as much money
because solar panel prices have increased.
So I think we're gonna end up paying more for the solar
for this project than we did the first project,
but still there's significant savings there
versus buying the power
under our current wholesale rate structure,
rate structure with TVA.
So those are the three projects I wanted to highlight,
but this is a very long list.
This is the five-year plan.
This is page one of the non-recurring list
for electric for page one.
I realize it's a bit of an eye chart.
Of course, you have your resolutions in front of you
for what is specific for FY27 or new project work orders.
And then this is page two of the non-recurring capital.
You see at the end of that, that's $121 million,
almost $122 million over the next five years
in capital improvements going into your electric system.
Non-recurring capital is, same thing vehicles.
Look at that vehicle number, $14.3 million in trucks.
We're in the pipe and wire and truck business.
It's amazing.
We have hundreds of vehicles on the road
and a number of them, especially the electric bucket trucks
are very expensive.
They're maybe a little less than a fire truck,
but they're in fire truck territory.
And you can see all the other items there
that are honestly fairly routine items
that we do every year.
And then you see there is the thought
that we may need to do some electric debt
in the out years in 2029, 2030.
Of course, we have lots of time to come back
and do more analysis and talk about that,
but our debt level on the electric side is quite low.
We can certainly manage that,
but in order to get these projects done in a timely manner,
that may be the right way to go.
So in future years, we'll come back and talk about that.
Here's the electric rates that you see here.
Green is for about 90% of the Huntsville utility
residential customers that have services less than 200 amps.
The sort of shaded pinkish, saminy color
is those services about the 10% of customers
that have a larger residential service,
over 200 amps in size.
And you see how we compare residential rates
with our peers in the area.
If I can, I will go back to a summary slide
I have up here at the beginning.
This is the total Huntsville utility budget,
which your council is involved down there
in the capital expenditures,
but you see the total water, electric, and gas budget
for the year is over almost $982 million.
We pay an awful lot of that,
about $550 million goes to TVA,
$38 million goes to buy natural gas
produced through our system,
but the remainder of that money stays here
as part of Huntsville utility's responsibility.
And you see in general,
we spend usually about a third of our money
that we keep here at Huntsville,
goes back into new capital construction.
That's usually our rule of thumb,
is about a third of the money goes back
into system improvements and new capital construction.
There is information here on factors,
influence in the budget,
and this is the case with all of them,
but you have this presentation,
you can read it at your convenience,
but we are seeing about 20, 25% cost increase
in materials and contracting,
that's been the case for a while,
we're continuing to see that at a pretty steady pace.
Vehicle pricing is up about 10 to 15% this year,
compared to prior years, fuel is 22% higher.
That certainly adds up a little bit as time goes on,
no doubt about it.
Again, when you have hundreds of vehicles
on the road every day.
Questions for Mr. Kelly regarding the electric budget.
Mr. Kling.
How does your maintenance budget
that deals with things like old power stations
that have to be replaced,
compared with the current year that we have now?
Yeah, that's a good question.
And I'll point out in this eye chart,
here, excuse me, I'm fighting summer allergies,
they seem to be getting the better of me at the moment.
You will see a number of transformer replacements
on this list, and that is to go back
and upgrade and improve existing substations.
So I guess it's really on the second page,
you see there's a number of these substations
that we're going back and upgrading and improving as we go.
Okay, I'm talking about power outages, of course.
Oh, okay, I'm sorry.
Yeah, so we have a team that is meeting regularly now
because we have our new outage management system in place,
it provides much more granular data.
That team meets monthly and goes through the areas
where we're seeing high frequency of outages,
and we're going through and putting in specific work plans
to address areas where we're seeing high frequency outages.
Mr. Meredith.
Yes, based on a couple of things that you mentioned,
the rooftop solar, in a very small sample,
could you give the general public
a little bit more information on how that is going to work?
Yeah, happy to.
Yes, and information's on our website,
and like I said, we got a little promotional video
out there as well.
Essentially, it's quite simple.
I can either pay TVA for that power
or I could pay our customers for that power,
and I'd rather pay the customer.
And so the rate that the customer gets paid
is based on our current TVA rates.
And so no customer's being subsidized,
no customer has to worry that certain solar customers
are getting a deal that other customers aren't.
It's the same energy,
I would just rather pay our customers for it
than pay TVA for it.
Is it, I know in some parts of the country,
I think it's called plug-in solar
where they can just get it, plug it in,
and somehow miraculously what they're pulling down
goes into your system.
Is that going to happen or is that a different program?
We're still talking about that.
So this rooftop solar program
has an inspected interconnection.
So the electrical inspector checks
and makes sure that everything is wired up right
and the disconnects are safe.
We have a little anxiety with just plug-in solar.
A lot of electric utilities do
because we had an electric employee a number of years ago
who was badly hurt and burned in electrocution
because we thought the circuit was off.
The customer had a generator running.
It was providing power back through the power line
and our employee burned his arm very badly.
And so we're very sensitive to that.
We want to make sure that there's proper safety protocols
associated with that.
With this rooftop solar program, we have that in place.
We need to think carefully about how we implement
a more diverse program.
It sounds great, thank you.
And I understand your concerns regarding the plug-in
makes perfect sense.
You had mentioned fiber.
Again, I've got very educated constituents.
And they have reached out and told me
that Google and H.U.'s partnership on fiber
that Google is walking away from that partnership.
Is there any truth to that?
No, we're actually about halfway through the contract.
It was a 20-year contract.
It was signed in 2016.
What has happened is that Google Fiber
is no longer Google Fiber.
It is now G-Fiber.
You probably noticed that's not just a marketing change.
They've actually changed the company.
So Alphabet is no longer the sole owner
of what was Google Fiber.
Alphabet is now a partial owner
along with other partners in G-Fiber.
And they merged with another company.
So they've been going through a transfer.
I understand that transfer is gonna be completed
by the end of this calendar year.
And the Alphabet side will be kind of pulled out.
But G-Fiber remains, and we got about 10 years left
in that contract.
Awesome, glad to hear that.
Thank you, sir.
Any other, Ms. Watkins?
Did I overlook the salaries of the employees in the budget?
No, ma'am, you didn't.
What the City Council approves by state statute
is new construction and equipment.
The regular operating expenses of the utility
are approved by the utility boards.
And that's what's laid out in the state statute.
Okay, thank you.
And the utility boards have approved that budget.
One last request.
On your bar that you gave us that showed the different rates
for water, gas, and electric.
Can you add Birmingham, Mobile, Montgomery to them
just for comparison?
I know you had Alabama Power.
Yeah, that's a great idea.
We talked about how we do in North Alabama,
but it'd be interesting to see how we compare
with those three cities.
Yeah, we could certainly do it on electric, of course.
Alabama Power tails the tail.
And you see it's quite a dramatic difference.
Usually about a 40% increase for those customers
compared to Huntsville customers.
But there could still be a health,
just that in water and gas.
But yeah, we absolutely can do that,
and I think it will look also quite good for Huntsville.
Other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed, the motion carries.
Brings us to legal department items and transactions.
18A is an ordinance authorizing the vacation
of a 15 foot utility drain adjudgment
between lots four and five.
Bel Air subdivision 7901 and 7903.
Martha Drive, is there a motion to approve?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little, second by the chair.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed, the motion carries.
18B is an ordinance authorizing the vacation
of a portion of utility drain adjudgment.
Lot one posits subdivision 415 Low Avenue.
Is there a motion?
So moved.
Motion from Mr. Little. Second.
Second by Ms. Watkins.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed, the motion carries.
18C is an ordinance authorizing the vacation
of utility drain adjudgment.
Lot two, Barnett Commercial Park phase two.
Is there a motion? So moved.
Motion from Mr. Little, second from Ms. Watkins.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Thank you.
Any opposed?
Motion carries.
18D is a resolution authorizing acceptance
of 1.425 acre and 0.861 acre tracts of land
for drain adjudgments.
Is there a motion to approve?
So moved.
Motion from Mr. Little, second from Ms. Watkins.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed, the motion carries.
We have no unfinished business items for action.
It brings us to new business items
for consideration or action.
These items will be approved in one motion
unless any member of the council wishes
to remove an item for discussion.
The reading of each item will be waived
unless the council member requests otherwise.
Are there any items that anyone wishes to hold
for separate consideration?
I have so.
Ms. Watkins.
E, G, H, I, J, K, L, E, M, P, now just stop at K.
Okay, okay.
E, G, H, I, J, K.
Any other items, Mr. Meredith?
O and Q and A, H.
Any other items?
Chair moves for consolidation of items 20A to D,
20F, 20L to N, 20P, 20R to AG.
Second.
Second from Mr. Little.
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
The motion carries.
I would suggest that we let the staff,
that's a lot of things to hold,
we'll let the staff kind of get wrapped themselves
around that and prepare to address them.
Could we please take a five minute break?
10 minute break, Mr. Little has proposed,
so that will bring us back here at 8.05.
So we are taking a break till 8.05.
10 minute break.
E.
Good.
Mr. Little, can you join us up here and,
Becca, tell him.
There he goes, okay.
Miss Watkins.
Miss Watkins, can you join us, please?
Mr. Kling.
I'll be in the middle, that'll be a pretty time.
Right, okay.
It's 8.05 and we will call this meeting back to order.
Present are council members, Little, Watkins and Kling.
He's right there.
We will begin with,
so these are items that have been held
for separate consideration.
20E, 20E is a resolution,
authorizing the mayor a portion of the proceeds
of a certain future borrowing
is to reimburse the 1990 capital plan,
capital projects fund of the city
for expenditures incurred prior to borrowing issuance.
Is there a motion to approve?
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little. Second.
Second from Miss Watkins.
Miss Smith.
Yes, Penny Smith, director of finances.
This evening, this item before you is very similar
to some other items that you have passed
out ahead of your debt.
So anytime that we look to issue debt,
we wanna right size the debt is what I call it,
so that we don't borrow too much or too little
for the different projects at hand.
This tool allows us to actually go in and start projects.
And so this specific one is for 21.5 million
is approximately the amount that we will borrow.
It is designed for three fire station properties
and then for the HVAC renovations that are being done
right now at our municipal justice public safety center.
Before we enter into discussion,
let the record show that Mr. Meredith has now joined us.
Are there any comments or questions?
What are the fire department properties
that you were talking about?
So the properties, so we are looking to, and I may.
Council members John Hamilton, city administrator.
So I think we've talked about a couple of times here
that we're beginning a process of replacing
several fire stations that need significant renovations,
but they're now based on the way that the city has grown,
they're really in the wrong place.
And so what you'll see in the capital plan
that will come to you here over the next couple of weeks
is funding to begin replacement of those stations.
Some of them need to be located on land
that city already owns,
but some also is land that we need to acquire.
But you've already approved one of the purchase agreements.
We've not yet closed on that property,
but we've got a couple more that we'll bring to you
over the next few months.
And it's all in support of the capital plan.
Is station three one of those?
It is.
Can we hold that and give me a chance
to have some neighborhood meetings concerning that?
Because I think that impacts a large area adjacent to it.
So it's absolutely one of,
we will bring the entire plan to you
and do that publicly,
and we can also go to count halls and things.
I just didn't want us to get financially committed
and then point the rug out.
What's before you tonight is allows us,
once you've approved certain expenditures,
once we do the borrow to reimburse our capital plan.
So like with many projects,
we will go ahead and begin the project.
We'll cash flow it out of funds available
in the capital plan.
And then when we go borrow for the full funding,
we reimburse the capital plan.
That's all that's before you tonight.
Any other comments or questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Motion carries.
20 G is a resolution authorized the mayor to accept
price quote from election systems and software Inc.
For all ballots and supplies, provisional kits,
express vote cards, programming,
coding of one ballot style, data conversion fees,
LNA testing, testing of poll books and onsite support
for the September 22, 2026 municipal runoff election.
Is there a motion to approve?
So moved.
Motion for Mr. Little. Second.
Second for Ms. Watkins.
Have anybody have questions for Ms. Edwards?
If you can just briefly explain what this is.
A lot of constituents don't know that this is
for the runoff election, correct?
If you can just briefly explain that.
Sure, thank you so much.
Good evening council, Mayor Battle,
Shandrick Edwards, city clerk.
This resolution authorized the mayor to accept election
systems and software quote for the upcoming runoff
to supply all of the ballots, the supplies necessary
for the runoff election.
And Madison County is supplying the machines, correct?
Yes, and you have already adopted that agreement.
We did not have to bring that a second time.
It already had a runoff.
I'm just repeating it for the public.
Yes, that language included.
So they won't think we got machines.
Oh no.
No, the agreement with Madison County will always have
the runoff language in it so we don't have to come back
to you a second time.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Any other questions or comments?
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
28 is the resolution authorizing the mayor
to enter into agreement between the city of Huntsville
and Alabama Department of Transportation
for installation of drainage structures on highway
and right of way for Alabama Highway 255,
Bob Wade Lane and Alabama Highway one, US Highway 431.
There are motion to approve.
Motion for Mr. Little, second for Ms. Watkins.
Ms. Martin.
Yes, Kathy Martin, Director of City Engineering.
So this item is an agreement with ALDOT.
It's really a permit for the city to do some improvements
within the state right of way associated
with the development of the southwest corner of SR255
and Memorial Parkway.
So this is the North Village improvements
or North Village development.
So you'll notice it's finally taking shape
and we're at this point in time where we need
to make some roadway improvements
within the state right of way for access to that development.
And so these are agreements to allow us to do such.
So this one in particular is for drainage improvements
along the parkway in the SR255.
Questions?
Comments?
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
20 aye is the resolution authorizing the mayor
to enter into agreement between the city of Huntsville
and Alabama Department of Transportation
for a permit to construct a turnout to provide access
to a state highway for Alabama Highway 255,
Bob Wade Lane and Alabama Highway 1, US Highway 431.
Is there a motion?
Move to approve.
Motion passed.
Mr. Little, second from Ms. Watkins.
Are there questions specific to this?
No, I pulled all these items so the public would know
exactly what's going on because we have a lot of questions
about the Northern Bypass.
And relative, and this is all-
Can you briefly say what's going on with this?
Yes, ma'am.
It's very similar to the last item where we are seeking
permission from ALDOT to do improvements
on their right of way.
So this one specifically is for turn lanes
along the parkway and the Northern Bypass
for access to North Village.
Thank you, Ms. Martin.
Any?
And the cost is?
There is no cost to the city.
It's just a permit to do the work within their right of way.
You should tell that up front.
Yes.
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Opposed?
Motion carried.
20J is a resolution to authorize Mayor Davenport
to agree between the City of Punsville
and Alabama Department of Transportation
for grading and our landscaping on right of way
for Alabama Highway 255, Bob Wade Lane,
and Alabama Highway, US Highway 431.
Motion to approve.
Motion from Ms. Watkins, second from Mr. Little.
Very similar to the last one.
This allows us to do the grading and landscaping
associated with the improvements to the state right of way.
Any comments or questions?
Thank you, Ms. Martin.
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
20K is a resolution to authorize Mayor to enter
into agreement between the City of Punsville
and Alabama Department of Transportation
for a permit to construct median crossover
for Alabama Highway 255, Bob Wade Lane,
and Alabama Highway 1, US Highway 431.
Move to approve.
Motion from Ms. Watkins, second from Ms. Little.
One more time, Ms. Martin.
Yes, ma'am.
This is for the intersection improvements.
So we'll have two signalized intersections
as part of that development.
One will be on SR 255 and the other one on North Parkway.
So with the approval of these agreements,
we can proceed to advertise for bids on that project.
Comments or questions?
All in favor, please indicate aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
20O is a resolution authorizing Mayor to execute
modification number seven to the original agreement
between the City of Punsville and VSP
for the purpose of renewing the city's
group vision benefits.
Is there a motion?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little.
Second.
Second from Ms. Watkins.
Yes, ma'am.
Byron Thomas, Director of Human Resources.
What you have before you is our annual renewal with VSP.
They provide a voluntary vision benefits for our employees.
Any questions?
Mr. Mayor.
And how much do we spend on that?
Well, it is a voluntary plan,
so it's all paid for by our employees.
So it's not a city's, necessary city sponsored.
Thank you, sir.
Other questions or comments?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
20Q is a resolution authorizing Mayor to execute
an amendment to the enrollment agreement
between the City of Punsville and Blue Cross
and Blue Shield of Alabama for third party
administrative services on the city's group health plan.
Is there a motion?
Move to approve.
Motion from Mr. Little.
Second.
Second from Ms. Watkins.
Yes, ma'am.
Mr. Thomas.
Byron Thomas, HR Director again.
What you have before you is our annual renewal
with Blue Cross Blue Shield
for our group health insurance plan.
This is a plan that provides medical benefits
to our employees and our retirees and COVID participants.
Any questions, Mr. Thomas?
Yes.
How much do we pay for this?
So annually we spend close to $40 million,
a little bit over $40 million a year
for our group health insurance,
but we do provide appropriate premiums
to our employees, retirees, and COVID participants.
Now, I just wanted the general public to know
where their money's going.
Yes, sir.
Thank you.
Other questions?
All in favor, please indicate.
Aye.
Opposed?
Motion carries.
And finally, 20...
20 AH.
AH is a resolution authorizing the mayor to enter
into a purchase and sale agreement
between the city of Huntsville and County Line 2.0 LLC
for the purchase of approximately 30 acres
of real property located near County Line Road
and Old Highway 20 in Limestone County.
Motion to approve.
Motion from Mr. Mayor.
Second.
Second from Ms. Watkins.
Mr. Davis.
Thank you, Madam President.
Shane Davis, Director, Urban Economic Development.
So council members, this is a purchase
and sale agreement option that shows a partnership
for this community.
So as we continue to grow west,
both SWATA, Solid Waste Disposal Authority
has been working with our office now for a couple of years,
not just for the west side,
but also in the Hampton Cove and North Huntsville area,
east side of the city for waste transfer stations,
which would greatly help our sanitation department
from having to pick up residential household waste
and bring it all the way down
into the southern part of the city.
These transfer stations would allow us
and people like the city of Madison,
people that are using solid waste
to turn their household garbage into energy for solid waste
from traveling so far back and forth.
And it's very common as most cities get very dense, right?
It makes sense.
So this location will be one of the first.
Here, it's located in the northwest quadrant
of County Line Road and Highway 20.
So if you really think about it,
it allows really for our sanitation department
from Research Park Boulevard West to use that,
allows the city of Madison to use that in Madison County.
So there's really no cost to the city.
So what we agreed to help SWATA do
is they identified areas for us to try to work
with property owners to commencement a sale.
So what you're doing is allowing us
to enter into this option on behalf of SWATA.
There's a section that allows us to transfer this option.
So it allows us to assign it to SWATA.
We've done this before.
It's very rare.
We've done it with Huntsville Utilities
and some other governmental agencies.
But because we dealt with a landowner
and there was trust in dealing with the city,
we agreed to bring this purchase option
before you to approve.
But ultimately, we would transfer this
to Solid Waste Disposal Authority
to actually close and make payment
should they decide to move forward.
They'll start some geotech and really make sure
that the soil and the ground is suitable
for their future use, we fully expect it to be.
And then at some point, we would have you assign this
to SWATA to actually close on the property.
I will tell you going forward,
the 30 acres is much more than what SWATA needs.
And that was by design in collaboration
with Huntsville Utilities.
You saw a lot of their growth.
The West Side, they have interest,
maybe putting an annex to help respond to residents,
both in Madison and Huntsville
and the portions of Lime Zone County they serve.
And then there's been some really light talk,
no funding, no future plans,
but went ahead and grabbed enough to where
if we needed to have a small annex for say public work
to get better services or sanitation.
So really SWATA is prepared to hold property
and as we grow and Huntsville Utilities grow,
have opportunity to provide services
in a much more efficient matter
to our residents in the future.
But ultimately, Solid Waste Disposal Authority
would be the purchaser of this property down the road.
Thank you.
Questions for Mr. Davis.
Mr. Meredith.
You did a great job explaining it, now I'm getting greedy.
Is there a way that or a potential
where in wintery inclement weather
we could stage some public works trucks there
that could move out to do something?
I would think so.
Once SWATA made that investment,
it would be very well suited for something like that.
Great, thanks.
Certainly they're gonna have a campus there.
So in that partnership.
Yes, sir.
Mr. Hamilton.
Mr. Meredith, when you see the capital plan
here in a week or so,
I have a plug in one of the out years
for development of some capability out there.
It's not necessarily specific to winter weather
or anything, it's right now,
it's just kind of figuring out exactly what the need is.
But I do think there is a point in the future
where we have both public works
and landscape management in particular,
maybe some others, but those two departments in particular
may actually have one of their zone teams
actually work out of that site potentially.
So what we're studying,
it's very similar to the North lock.
So right now the teams that cover the north of the city
and portions of the West Likin to CRP
actually work out of a panics we have up north.
This would be similar to that potentially.
Great, thank you, sir.
Third, sirs.
Any other comments or questions?
All in favor, please.
Any opposed?
Motion carries that concludes the items for consideration.
We'll move now to new business items for introduction.
These are for introduction only items 21A to 21D
are all specific to budget items.
In the interest of full public transparency
and to give the council and the public opportunity
to consider them, a work session will be held
on September 18th at 11 o'clock.
And then they will be considered for approval
at the regular council meeting on September 24.
21A is the introduction of an ordinance
to adopt the city of Huntsville annual budget
for fiscal year 2027, beginning October 1, 2026.
21B is the introduction of an ordinance
amending ordinance number 89-79
to provide all eligible employees
of the city of Huntsville a cost of living adjustment,
a COLA as reflected in the first pay period
in the fiscal year 2027 budget,
effective October 12, 2026.
21C is the introduction of an ordinance amending
of chapter two administration article seven departments,
department heads and other appointed officers
of the code of ordinances of the city of Huntsville,
Alabama.
21D is the introduction of an ordinance amending
ordinance number 89-79 classification and salary plan
ordinance for the addition of a public safety salary schedule
to provide pay rates for certified law enforcement
and fire suppression positions.
21E is the introduction of an ordinance
to amend section 8.2 appointment rate
of ordinance 04-315 personnel policies and procedures manual.
21F is the introduction of an ordinance
to amend ordinance number 89-79 classification
and salary plan ordinance.
21G is the introduction of an ordinance
to exempt hearing aids from city sales and use taxes.
This has been properly introduced.
We have had a request from Mr. Meredith
that unanimous consent of the council would be asked for
in order to consider this tonight.
Mr. Meredith, would you please state the reason
for that request?
The reason is because this council is at the opportunity
to, excuse me, enact relief from the hearing aid sales tax
since 2024, and I know I have been blissfully ignorant
of the fact that we could do that,
and now that it has been brought to my attention,
and frankly all our attentions, from the very good work
that the advocacy community has done,
I think it would be a great thing for this council
to show the public that we actually do listen to them,
we hear what they're saying, and we wanna take action
on this as soon as possible so that they know
that this council is firmly committed to listening to them
and pushing forward on policies that are important to them.
Are you going to make a motion for unanimous consent?
Well, you're the president.
I mean, I thought you would do that.
I will not make that motion.
Okay, well, I'll make the motion for, I move.
Second.
Yes, sir.
Or do we do the motion first and second
then the question?
We can discuss it.
So I make the motion.
Second.
Thank you.
So the motion for unanimous consent of the council
to consider this item has been made by Mr. Meredith,
seconded by Ms. Watkins.
All in favor of what we do this by,
we will do this as a roll call vote.
Mr. Meredith, how do you vote?
Aye.
Mr. Bitt, Mr. Kling?
I vote no, and I wanna come back and explain my answer
when we get done.
Mr. Little.
No.
Ms. Watkins. Yes.
And the chair votes no.
We do not have unanimous consent to consider this item.
And he, no, he doesn't need to make a comment.
We have dealt with it.
You know what, I'm going to recognize Mr. Kling.
Mr. Kling, go ahead.
What comment would you like to make?
I had asked before, Mr. Meredith,
other people are in time.
Turn your microphone on instead of screaming.
I don't think I need the microphone, do I?
I think you should for recording purposes.
Well, thank you.
If they need my help, I'll be glad to provide it.
Mr. Kling, do you have a comment?
I do.
We are getting ready to take up the budget
and to do something like this,
Mr. Meredith brings us out.
That's great.
I've had a lot of positive discussions
with good people in the community.
I understand the difference between Huntsville
and Madison's and the disadvantage.
And so I'm very positive toward this concept.
But at the same time,
we've got a budget that we're going to present.
Is Mr. Meredith got any budget offsets he's going to show?
Has he got anything that he's going to show
about how this would go?
Are we doing something wrong by doing this
before the budget actually comes up on the table?
So I think it needs to be simultaneously
instead of one before the other.
Thank you, Mr. Kling.
We will go on then.
I would like to also make a comment.
I believe you made a comment at the beginning.
If you had bothered to read this,
you would know that there is significantly zero
budget impact.
And this is not actually part of the budget.
I cannot take this and make a budget amendment on it.
It has to be its own separate thing.
We're talking about 100,
according to Ms. Robinson's comment at a public forum
during the campaign, you're talking about $126,000.
Okay?
It's nothing, Mr. Kling,
compared to the budget that we are going to pass.
So your indignation is wasted because this is zero impact.
The only time it kicks in if it's passed tonight
is in September of next year for one month.
So why are you so indignant
and demanding that this be offset?
There are no offsets required for this.
Well, we are going to have this conversation
at the work session,
I'm sorry, on the 24th when this item is considered.
So please save your comments until then,
and we will move on.
21H is an introduction of an ordinance
amending chapter eight business, Mr. Kling?
Mr. Kling?
21H is the introduction of an ordinance
amending chapter eight business,
article four, vehicle for hire, division two,
livery vehicles of the code of ordinances
of the city of Huntsville, Alabama,
to amend the taxi vehicle for hire rate.
20I is the introduction of an ordinance
annexing 236.58 acres of land
lying on the south of Huntsville Brownsbury Road,
west of Greenbrier Parkway.
21J is the introduction of an ordinance
declaring certain real property as surplus
and authorizing the mayor to enter into purchase
and sale agreement between the city of Huntsville
and Lehman Ferry LLC.
That concludes our business there.
The mayor would like to have an opportunity
to share nominations with the public.
Thank you, thank you, Madam President and council,
and I'm sorry, Mrs. In my comments.
I would like to announce appointment of George Nowlin
to the City Tree Commission,
effective October 9th, 2026,
to expire October 8th, 2028.
The reappointment of Mimi Potthoff
to the City Tree Commission,
effective October 10th, 2026,
to expire October 9th, 2028.
And the reappointment of Jesse Horton
to the City Tree Commission,
effective October 10th, 2026,
to expire October 9th, 2028.
Thank y'all for letting me put that in.
Thank you, prefect, let's keep that on the record.
We will now take up second roster public comments.
This portion of the meeting is reserved
for persons wishing to address the council
on matters relating to the city business,
whether or not such items are on the meeting agenda.
I have here a list of persons who have signed up to speak.
When called, approach the microphone,
state your microphone, state your name,
home address, and city residence.
Each speaker may address the council for three minutes.
Speakers shall refrain from entering into a dialogue
with council members or city staff
and from making comments regarding good name and character
of any individual.
I will call each person and the person
who will be succeeding them so you can be ready to come up.
The first person to sign up is someone
who is not a stranger at all to us.
Our former council member,
Frances Akeridge has joined us tonight.
We will start with Ms. Akeridge.
She will be followed by Omri Davis.
Welcome, Ms. Akeridge.
Good evening, council members, I'm Frances Akeridge.
The address on the sign-in sheet is correct.
And city of?
City of Huntsville.
Thank you.
So when I first moved here, it's been 20 years now,
I looked for some information about the budget.
It was on the website, it was three years old.
And I had to run it down and find the current budget.
And I'm starting my few minutes to say thank you,
Penny Smith, for evidence of continuous improvement
in the presentation of it and the legibility
and the ability to learn from it.
That kind of professionalism is something
that I looked for because of my,
not only my business background,
but also because I grew up in a military family.
My comments are about more now about etiquette.
A good way to make a first impression
for all of our new city residents
is that they call here that the person answering the phone
speaks legibly, clearly, and does something
on the order of what I was taught to do as a child.
Good afternoon, my name is Frances Akeridge.
I would say after good afternoon.
Hello, this is Frances Akeridge,
Lieutenant Colonel Wint's residence.
It was clear somebody knew where they had reached,
and I recommend, Mr. Byron,
that we do the same thing throughout the city
because when I call, sometimes I have to,
and it's not a hearing problem,
I can't understand somebody.
We all have one chance to make a good impression.
In the leadership training and other training that you do,
it is imperative that somebody who's answering that phone
sees themself as an ambassador to the people
who are calling.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
We will now hear from Omri Davis,
who will be followed by David Snyder.
Is Omri Davis here?
Then David Snyder, and who will be followed
by Liliana Painter.
Hello, my name is Mix David Snyder.
My information is written correctly on the sheet.
I live in Huntsville, Alabama.
Thank you, sir.
I wanted to talk a little bit about racism,
racism in Huntsville,
and I wanted to show a little bit of support
for a Black History Museum to be installed in Huntsville.
I know that several people from Omega Psi Phi
have advocated that for some time now.
I remember a while back when there was racist graffiti
that was put on the mid-city mural,
if anybody here remembers that.
I remember watching them paint over that,
or hearing about them paint over that.
I remember hearing reports about restaurants
that had suffered verbal attacks, racist, vitriol.
I remember covering up,
this is I think when I was homeless,
and I did a lot of walking around in this city,
and I remember finding racist graffiti myself,
and with my own hands covering up racist graffiti
in this town.
I've watched one of our city council members,
John Meredith, make claims
about receiving discriminatory practice.
I remember when our councilwoman,
Michelle Watkins, first came on
and was on the receiving end of racist vitriol
via email, I believe, or some other communication,
and I remember reaching out to our councilwoman Watkins
about that.
These are examples of explicit,
outright, in our face racism.
We also have, there are systemic issues
that we had the Smithsonian come through
with the bias inside us,
and we kind of showed that value of seeing that
there is an implicit bias in all of us.
I have shared, there's an article,
I believe it's called the Expert Mechanism
on Racial Justice, it's a UN expert mechanism.
I remember sharing a document that came out of that
when they did a visit to the US,
and I remember sharing that document
with the entire council before.
These are examples of racism in our communities,
and history is not just something
that is represented in the past in museums,
it's also represented in the present
with our daily actions and our daily perceptions
that then shape the future, right, so it's important.
I wanted to call out a call for accountability
and say that I believe that our council member,
my council member, Bill Kling,
should recant statements that there is no racism
in Huntsville because I don't believe
that that was an appropriate comment to make.
Thank you, sir.
We will now hear from Liliana Painter,
who will be followed by Harold Kemp.
Please.
Good evening, council.
My name is Liliana Painter,
and my address is correct on the sheet.
City of Residence.
A city of residence is Huntsville.
Thank you.
I've called Madison County my home since 2014.
I've experienced Huntsville's growth
through several lenses, as a homeowner,
an educator, a small business owner,
and most importantly, a mother raising her children here.
I've watched our neighborhoods grow,
businesses come in, and more families choose Huntsville.
I believe growth is a good thing,
but we have to be intentional about who the growth serves.
Tonight, we're investing in our workforce,
considering hundreds of acres of development
and annexation, continuing to invite people
and businesses to choose Huntsville.
I support investing in our public servants,
but if we can find room in our budget
to address compensation, we should bring that same urgency
to affordability for our residents.
Tonight, we're finally considering eliminating
the city sales tax on something as essential as hearing aids.
So I would highly recommend thinking
about that more clearly.
We're also considering another 236 acres for annexation,
a new tax increment financing district,
and more than 800 acres moving through major zoning
and rezoning actions.
When we annex land to create a TIF district
or rezone hundreds of acres,
we aren't just moving lines on a map.
We're adding people, infrastructure demands,
and long-term obligations that outlast any single vote.
Residents deserve to see the math
before decisions are finalized, not after.
And if we're inviting newcomers to the Star of Alabama,
we should welcome them as Huntsvillians.
But we also cannot forget the people
who already built their lives here.
Developers benefiting from our growth
should be held to their commitments.
Growth should not leave residents and taxpayers
carrying the consequences, because ultimately,
this comes back to representation.
No elected official, no candidate, no institution
is above the voters.
The polling place belongs to the voters.
City Hall belongs to the people.
And public office belongs to the people,
not the person temporarily entrusted with it.
Huntsville has grown tremendously.
Now our representation, accountability,
and capacity have to grow with it.
I'll give you back your time, thank you.
Thank you, and finally, we will hear from Harold Kemp.
Is Mr. Kemp still here?
He is not, that was our last speaker.
Then do we have a motion to adjourn?
Motion for Mr. Little, thank you.
Thank you, council members.
We'll see you for the work session
on September 18th at 11 o'clock.